what up guys welcome to before I start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification Bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos before I start I have a
couple announcements the first being
that we have two clips two clips
channels the first being just pearly
clips and the second being Pearl daily
make sure you go subscribe to both we
have two different editors on the
account so you get a little bit
different feel of like different types
of Clips the second announcement is that
we have four membership tiers if you
want to be a part of the chat tonight
sign up for our five dollar a month
membership this is really important it
helps us get equipment updates we really
want to get an 8K camera so make sure
you sign up for that the second tier is
you get to see behind the scenes Vlogs
and you also get to see our Discord this
Pet house is cool right guys if you want
to see what it looks like sign up for
the 10 tier we're dropping that video
next week on top of that our third tier
you get to connect with us on social
media meaning you have direct access to
me through message images and the fourth
tier you get a one-on-one call with me
once a month you honestly get so much
value out of this call because a lot of
people want to grow on YouTube and I
have helped people get to a hundred
thousand subscribers 50 000 subscribers
twenty thousand like I I kill YouTube
okay
um
um next do not forget to follow my
Instagram it's just dot pearly things
you have to type in the whole thing
because I am Shadow banned on Instagram
right now they keep like Mass reporting
my pages
going crazy I'm also also follow my Tick
Tock
justpirelythings.4 and dot five um they
took away my first three accounts and
I'm on my fourth and my fifth account
um so go follow those
um also thank you guys for 400 000
subscribers
um that's a big accomplishment for the
channel and we could not do it without
you I'm so grateful that you guys let me
do my dream job every day so I could not
do it without you
um last thing DM Eddie if you want to
come on the show um his Instagram is in
the description
so today we have a lovely panel why
don't we go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and a fun fact either that you know or
about yourself so starting with you and
then go around my name is Taylor I'm 23.
I'm not in a relationship
um I don't really know a fun fact about
myself what do you what do you like to
do
I like to dance okay
uh my name is Melissa I'm 23. I'm single
and I can play the piano
and my name is Maria I'm 21 and I don't
actually know a fun fact it's like when
people ask me oh tell me a fun fact I'm
like
I can't think of it what do you like to
do seven
I feel like I just do a lot like what
little things of a life that makes sense
okay what's like a little thing you like
to do
um I'm into music okay music what type
of music
um I'm literally varied in genres like
from Jazz to like okay Jazz that's cool
it could be your fun fact you like jazz
music
good
um Soraya I'm 29.
I'm
29 and my relationship today is I guess
it's complicated
or like single not ready to mingle kind
of thing
um a fun fact about me I'm one of 14 so
I'm Number 13 or 14.
siblings yeah yeah there's 14 of me
okay
um hi everybody my name is a fun fact
about me is I like Ceramics oh and I'm
29. and I'm single
yeah
me okay so I'm a star I'm 27 I'm single
and a fun fact I once missed a call from
Nicki Minaj
you what yeah
what was she doing what did you do was
she busy so I am queen of do not disturb
now my phone is always on do not disturb
you cannot get through to me like I'm
not Emergency Services call them yeah um
so that's what my situation was and I
woke up the next morning and my best
friend was like oh my gosh I was moving
a key and we're trying to call you
you're such an idiot so that was years
ago and it still hurts it still hurts oh
my God that would hurt me too yeah
that's really sad yeah sad what can I do
I'll meet her one day
affirmations exactly so
um today today's topic because we are
talking about cheating
um so
um I wanted to go around have you ever
been cheated on and how did you find out
yeah I've been cheated on firm I've had
two boyfriends and they've both cheated
on me
I think the first time I found out was
through my friend uh she found some
messages and sent them to me and the
second time
um a video of my boyfriend actually got
put on YouTube
of him on FaceTime to another girl doing
not so good things what I found the
video how to do I like how how was he
filmed like who filmed it it was like
someone screen recorded the FaceTime
call and I got a message on Instagram
and this woman basically said like if
you don't give me money I'm gonna post
it I was like go ahead post it I said if
he's cheating on me well I'm not gonna
help him yeah yeah is he is he famous
why did they put him on YouTube
I think she just wanted like attention
but it got taken down anyway so
yeah what was he doing on there
well you know you know when you go on
FaceTime sometimes like guys gonna face
time to a girl and no you know we pulled
out yeah
he was having phone sex with this girl
oh what is it is he a girl or a shower
you might as well continue going around
yeah
um so yeah I've been cheated on before
um once to my knowledge
um and basically it was a long time ago
but I found out two years later because
I started dating without knowing again
one of his friends and then his friend
told me all by the way three years ago
what was the reason yeah
obviously by that time
that time what's the plan
maybe for
yourself yeah probably I mean it did
would you go would you guys respect a
man that does that no way
Jose is not loyal I mean I won't even
respect a girl doing that do you get
what I mean like I'm gonna come to you
as a woman no not even that like if for
me if I if my friend cheated
on a guy and then he was then dating me
I wouldn't be talking about her
especially at the time if I didn't tell
him why am I telling him after you
wouldn't really be dating him anyway
just say even if it wasn't yeah even if
by coincidence I didn't know that was
her man and he was to come in my life I
wouldn't then because if I didn't tell
him then why would I tell him now to get
what I mean no point infection up the
past yeah I kind of wish he didn't
because I just got hurt for no reason
basically but it is charge it did you
break up with him immediately
um well I wasn't I wasn't with him
anyway like I found out three years
later so I wasn't even with him it was
such a weird one so yeah I guess it was
good that you found out later because
yeah I mean it's less heartbreaking in
that sense but it still hurts like oh
okay then you need to know yeah like I
just I'd rather have not known that's
the truth I was fine
it is what it is
um yes I have been cheated on before I
just had that instinctive when I said I
wasn't through his phone I literally
just went on his phone and I saw
everything I needed to see when you see
who shall finding it yeah that's what a
guy told me a guy told me if you look at
any time you always find something you
have an issue with I don't think you
will no but I just got handed the phone
right in front of me it was right in
front of me all down so it's like I just
I was like oh what did you what did you
find
um
a lot of messages okay he was like what
are you doing for Valentine's Day
um
so yeah go with that [ __ ] over there
okay have fun that was literally how it
was did you dump him right away
um or did you did you stay with him for
a little bit for how long
um it's always the way it works
for four more months and then did he
cheat again
that's always the way
um if you went through his phone and you
didn't find anything would you have told
him you went through his phone
the thing is so he just kind of like
gave me his phone and it was like on
open yeah that makes sense like all the
messages were right in front of me that
was God
so it's like
I don't know maybe I would have told him
I went through his phone okay like if
yeah yeah okay go ahead
gosh my story is a bit long I don't know
how much time I've got are you can if
it's interesting go ahead
um yeah it's okay so basically
his cheating was never confirmed he's
always denied it even though I've got
substantial evidence to say that he's
cheated on me he will still deny it
um he so
at Uni there was three of us or four of
us that were friends there was three
guys and then me
um and then when I broke up with my
partner at the time I was only about 19
or something
um I started dating him he was like a
friend that obviously I'd known him for
about two years like homie Harbor yeah
yeah because me I like I like to be
connected to your mind to get what I
mean and he was he wasn't like the
friend didn't work out so you're like oh
there's his friend and then no no no no
no no so he was my friend so we were
almost he like made it out of the he
made out of the friend zone oh but but
he was friends with your ex too no no he
was all so we were just the uni friends
we were just a bunch of friends and then
so yes when I became single they all
approached me and I chose him oh okay
okay okay yeah but that you're there was
there was no connection with it yeah it
was just I was single for the first time
and it was just like okay cool
um so
I was dating him we were together for
about I'll say two years and in between
that I found a few things but he'll
always deny it cool I then moved into a
property with one of our mutual friends
girlfriends so one of the guys from the
circle his girlfriend
and me and her live together they then
moved in with us because they were meant
to get their own property but it was
just like we might as well just like all
live in one place so it was that cool
everyone used to come to our house it
was like the uni little hot spot my
friend that was dating the girl
he went away so he went to his country
and he was there for some time and I
started noticing a different behavior in
her like her her pajamas started getting
shorter they started going out at the
same time or they'll try to stay in at
the same time and I thought this is
getting a bit awkward like
anyway she they then disappeared one day
at the same time she said she's going to
see her mum he said he's going to see
his mum and we had a group chat they're
not responding on anything you know at
the same time so I thought is it me or
like is this too much of a coincidence
anyway
um when I when I asked him well I said
to him there's definitely someone she's
cheating with because she's you know
dressing up a bit more she came home
that night and she was talking about
like you know she was talking about some
crazy stuff so I was messaging him like
oh I think I know like she's definitely
cheating but I think I know who really
feels like yeah try find out I was like
okay so obviously you know then the next
day he disappeared for the whole night
she despaired for the whole night so I
thought nothing of it cool I went back
to the flat alone
um
the week later we had all our uni
friends come round and one of her Dopey
friends came and she didn't know how to
use just eat so she's taking her laptop
now to go and just eat
as she's gone on to put the postcode in
she obviously doesn't know how to use a
laptop so I said okay let me try use it
I've gone to click on the postcode and
it says cr0 and I'm thinking she doesn't
have no friends in Croydon like who the
hell where's she going in Croydon so
I've now memorized the postcode and I'm
not going to him like yo yo give me your
phone I think I know who she's cheating
with and he was like yeah yeah like try
it try it like see what you know so I've
now gone and put in the postcode
uh oh sorry before I get there basically
when he came back from his night away we
had a massive argument he left the house
I went through his pocket and I saw a
receipt for Hallmark hotel right so
obviously he came back he explained that
he was at his mom's but he needed
um some time away from her so he just
booked a hotel for himself I said why
didn't tell me anyway yeah cool long
story short he needed some time alone so
as I've now gone to put the postcode on
his phone the pin drops at Hallmark
Hotel oh wow oh so they were together
well this is it so straight away in the
whole group of friends I've now
confronted her and I said how the hell
do you know Hallmark hotel and because
he's such a good Prof prolific liar he
goes I made her order me food
I said sorry and then he's now told me
that he's got her to order food because
he couldn't trust anyone else to order
food because everyone else would have
told me he's at the hotel
so long story short yeah I found that he
was cheating with my flatmate
and did you break up with him
no because he convinced me that that it
was that it wasn't did he really can
like come on no he can when I said when
I said you wanted to be convinced no no
why saying he convinced me I called my
friend straight away and I said listen
your girlfriend's a cheat blah blah blah
this is what's happened he then spoke to
her apparently she showed proof that
they were they called for the food or
what whatever so he then convinced me
that his girlfriend wasn't cheating on
him she he then made me feel bad that
I'm even making such a big allegation I
still said yeah I'm still moving out I'm
not gonna lie like I gave him my notice
um so yeah he convinced me that they
didn't do a thing so how long did you
stay with him after that a good two more
years two more years and are you
the most interesting part
um what made you switch like from being
convinced to not convinced I was never
not I was never fully not convinced oh
okay so yeah you said you said he
convinced you yeah he tried convincing
me so obviously I still stayed there so
okay this is where I'm a little confused
you were you were convinced or you were
not I was still like because I thought
you maybe found more evidence later no I
found more evidence later oh okay I
definitely found more evidence so I know
that he definitely did but he still
would deny it okay okay yeah yeah okay
what was the interesting so what was
interesting is um so a couple of years
later now university has happened and
we've all graduated you know she was a
[ __ ] on graduation cool
um we've all me and my friend we broke
up because he felt like we I broke up
the Friendship cool
um then a couple of years later I was at
home like we were living together and
then I was going through
I was on laptop and we used to download
you know like we had LimeWire or
whatever then so you just download shows
and as I was going on um a show to watch
the profile a folder came up and it said
please insert USB and her name was a
show that we used to watch so I won't
say the show because obviously it was
disclose who she is but it was she had
so I thought it's the show that he was
watching right it was on his recently
viewed so I've gone to click here and it
says oh please insert the USB
so he's always obviousb on his keys so
I've now inserted the first one and it
wasn't showing so I'll inserted the
second one and it came up with a folder
and it had all her pictures oh wow
so I've now gone onto my computer to go
see what like what's on what else is on
there and there was no folders like no
files and I was like this is so
confusing and I was I'm not tech savvy
like I don't do technology so I've had
to now go on Google find how to unhide
folders I've gone to unhired folders and
there was about 60 folders of girls
pictures that he must have been chatting
to over the time and he was saving them
wow
he just had a file of the white Bank in
it oh were they like naked explicit yeah
whatever like whatever folders he had
like so so when so when was that that
was that was the end of our relationship
okay that then it actually ended yeah
okay yeah then I found out that he was
actually then cheating on me with his ex
oh so that's what how many how many
girls total
a lot I I still wouldn't he'll still
deny but what did you with the weights
so so you found you found a picture like
a whole folder of naked girls multiple
pictures not even just naked the sun
might have been just oh okay innocent
one right but it was a part of his
collection and he said and he said that
this is nothing yeah he told me that he
she only like the gold the flatmate only
sent him pictures because he was given
her advice on what to wear I was like
what you got one like what do you mean
you're advising her but yeah that was It
was obviously you know um he tried lying
as much as he could okay and then that
was the end of the relationship yeah
yeah okay uh
actually was there anything we missed in
the story okay so basically oh there's I
just felt sorry I just felt like you had
more to say
basically his girlfriend his ex at the
time I used to see messages from a girl
called s coming up and I had doubts it
was his ex right and he was like no no
no it's not anyway when I found that
them pictures he then said you know what
I can't do this anymore like I'm done
you're always doubting me I said yeah
because there's reasons cool then
obviously he broke up with me then the
next day I had taken the number s's
number and I called it the next day and
I said oh hey so and so is you know who
with you
and I heard him start laughing at the
background and he had a very specific
laugh so it confirmed that he was with
her but obviously she denied it she was
like why would I be with him but yeah so
so you kind of had like red flags like
all four years would you say
pretty yeah pretty much yeah okay and I
stayed like a dumb girl yeah okay but
the first instance you caught him
cheating you said
well obviously I had the doubts over the
four years right yeah yeah yeah go ahead
um no I've never had an experience like
that
um or I don't know if a man's cheated on
me I don't know about it I don't search
you know okay that's it you don't know
no no it might have happened but you
just don't know I just don't know I
don't look for the thing is with men if
you look for it you'll find it if you
want to find it
talking to you yeah oh yeah yeah same
problem
um yeah I don't look for that kind of
thing so yeah as far as I know no but
maybe okay let's start here yeah um I
reckon I have I never really saw
anything
in particular but I had very strong
convictions that I was and then you know
like when this is why I say sometimes
sorry yeah men like I'm provoked because
I I knew but then I'd ask him and then
sometimes he'd say no and then other
times he'd be like oh yeah because you
know what I'm making food safe I'm like
no just tell me the truth it's fine
and he's like okay yeah and then in
other times when I do bring up he's like
I didn't say that I'm like yeah you did
so I never really found anything
properly but I just I really need you
think you wanna know
do you know what I can handle the truth
I never ask questions if I can't handle
that answer like I will be ignorant I
will happily live ignorantly but I would
ask a question when I know that I can
handle the truth and I think doesn't
matter what it is doesn't matter how bad
it is please always tell me the truth
yeah I don't care how bad it is but yeah
it's easier just to be truthful always
like don't waste anybody's time then and
I hate it when like oh you can't handle
the truth and it's like no I can handle
the things
I think sometimes we
I think sometimes women say you can
handle the truth but you act
I can't because I think and I think
that's why a lot of guys would then like
even like each other because a lot of
women relax just tell me and we'll talk
about it but when he then tells you the
truth it's now a whole argument it's a
whole thing you can't you don't you
don't have a proper conversation about
it which is why I love them lie about it
you know where a lot of girls go wrong
men will test whether they can be
truthful of you throughout the
relationship yeah and you don't Club
those little tests where you might say
something and see how you respond to it
it might not be a big thing but that
response tells us a lot about how you
behave yeah so when it comes to the big
things there's no waiting to tell you
anything no but you know what it is the
response she gives you when she first
finds out when she says she can handle
the truth is going to be far better than
when she finds out you've lied to her
because that's when she's vandalizing
your car she get what I mean if he gets
quiet if it gets caught the reactions
are far worse so even if she says she
can handle it and she reacts it's going
to be a lot more better than when she
finds out that you've lied on top of
them do you know I've seen women with
the same energy Carnival I see I'm like
I get why the cat the guy was scared but
he still cheat in the first place
huh I don't think guys can handle the
truth any better no they can't they they
don't I will die oh you guys get so
bruised my immune system will shut down
hold down on the spot if we told you the
truth about all the things that like we
thought when you asked for our opinion
we're dead yeah I'm I'm on this whole
day don't do it I'll go I'll end up in
hospital
I'm glad that you admit that
Eagles fragile serious what about you
Auntie
yeah a few times a few times
I can think of two times two different
times
and once
my boyfriend at the time was supposed to
we're supposed to go out he didn't turn
up so
I went to his house and young lady
outside the door oh yeah
and this is you know
and she goes oh he's upstairs and said
oh I'll come up
and he was in bed are you saying freezer
and he just looked like threesome he
likes to have a heart attack all the
colors just drained out of his face
I just said hi
she said would you like a cup of coffee
I said yes please
she went downstairs to get the coffee
and he looked at me and I said would you
want to say do you want to freak out I
said no I'm not going to do that I said
the poor girl said she don't know any
different and she's come up and she was
just like hi and she's trying to cuddle
him in bed because they were in bed and
he's sort of like and I'm saying is that
your man and she said yeah I said hug
him up girl
were you the main chick of the side
chick that was the main you were the
main yeah but that was it but I just
after that I just terrorized him nicely
who did she think you were the right
thing to told me she thought I was his
friend oh god oh well why would you cut
it because I've got a lot of male
friends and she always saw us with a lot
of men together but obviously the energy
you came up as well wouldn't be someone
that you would assume it was a bigger
because he's very calm and Collective
what am I supposed to do it's not awful
no but I should say most girls the
instant response would be to run
upstairs they're even trying to oh
that's that's
the same time I was like hi I'm here I'm
coming you went to torture you wanted to
talk to him yeah as you should like this
is all right as far as she was concerned
I was his friend
like when I was talking to the guys
because we'd all hang out around this
I'd put around she said oh he's not in
you know I'm just cooking I gotta put
them into the shop to get something I'll
find them I said this what you're having
for dinner right
this is what you're having for dinner
yeah you just want to play it at parties
for me and then he wouldn't invite her
I'm like what you mean you're not coming
tell him I invited you I was mopping my
ears more psycho and then no and then I
just left it at that but I didn't I
think he cheated on her because another
time I just saw all of his car had all
paint all over oh damn I was just like
what happened to you
supposed to do it's not her fault so
moral of the story is pull up
no don't ever come for yourself
I'm saying to like torture him over like
time then just like go ham on them
because you could have easily just taken
their jaw off and then that'd be it over
done with don't you know he's taking his
jaw off who's your guys
forget about it I hurt my hands
I could never hit a man because if he
hit me back it will hurt so I agree with
that if I hit a man I'd expect him to
hit me but that's what I'm saying
stupid I'm not gonna hit a man and
knowing that he's gonna hit me back no
way
yeah and another time I got cheated on
um I was a supervisor in a bus garage
and I got a phone call my boyfriend was
a night bus driver
and I got a phone call gonna pass a
message onto this person and I said yeah
I can also speak and she said his
girlfriend
I said okay then and I haven't seen it
for a couple of years
and then when he was on his break I said
oh can I have a word he said yeah no
problem
your girlfriend she wants you to phone
her back he flipped out I was so calm
you freaked out I said to the manager I
said you're gonna need a new driver in a
couple of months it's been a couple of
months he was gone
that was it because and that was one and
the thing is I made him we had like this
relationship contract that I'd signed
and nominated and got him to sign then
it was like you're telling me because if
I find that you're cheap that's it yeah
and I hit her so he just flipped her I
was in a personal contract you wrote up
yeah I typed it and everything wow
laminated it got to sign it of what I
expected and you break any one of them
that's it
no but I feel that I needed it to do
with it with him yeah
why didn't you freak out like so many
girls when that happened
um like I think a lot of times we have a
hard time like remaining calm
how were you able to control your
emotions I didn't take it personally
it's just a man and he just it was there
available and he just it happens take
notes so you know I didn't take it
personally I mean I didn't think yeah oh
my God she's sexier than me or she can
do this I just thought the opportunity
came up because as far as I'm concerned
you've got a few more friends go ahead
because it could be a female friend
you're gonna sleep with it could be a
woman down the road that you meet up so
it don't really matter so I'm not going
to say you can't have female friends so
we had a female friends and that was one
of them so
um did you break up with him after that
instantly he knew it was over because he
signed the contract yeah what about the
other one instantly instantly yeah what
do you think of girls that stay in those
situations do you think that's good or
bad
then they're going to start talking
about trauma after that
it's up to them but whatever you get I
mean if it can happen once I mean you
can accept it if you want to accept it
but
if you accept it then put up with it in
it don't say nothing yeah because a lot
of times like we accept it and then
complain about trauma later but yeah we
accepted it yeah we put ourselves
through it yeah I'll give that I mean
you've got to think to yourself what
value you're putting on yourself that
you're staying I think a lot of
um women stay with men I think young
like when I was young I was like no I've
never tolerate a man cheating or
whatever but it's harder when you're in
a relationship especially when you're
emotionally involved for you to just up
and leave I think modern women like
being cheated on do you think but that's
because but that's because modern women
think men are monogamous
saying they're not no I'm just saying
only one out of three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year if you wanted a man that didn't
cheat you could find one pretty yes but
they're the ones that you're not
attracted to you right right monogamous
men that often might not cheat on you
aren't the ones that women are attracted
to because women like men that are like
alcohol well women find 80 of men
unattractive so most women are sleeping
out of their league or dating out of
their league and so if you choose to do
that that's what comes with it yeah and
most of them guys that everyone goes for
is going to be a select pack yeah yeah
that's but that's the thing yeah so I'm
saying like if we like those guys how
can we be mad that they cheat because
there's lots of guys that don't and I
think this is the problem is because in
society now where we don't allow men to
be polygamous especially in the Western
countries and then that's the men that
are often caught in cheating and
families are breaking whereas like parts
of Asian Africa where polygamy is a lot
more accepted men have their children
multiple wives and they raise them and
their society is a lot more stable why
don't you think that the owners should
be on the men to know what they can and
cannot do so for me if you know that
you're a man who wants to have multiple
women you should know what you want and
you should make that clear 100 so 100 I
don't I'm not here for you being in a
monogamous religion because I've had
guys say that where the inner monogamous
relationship they cheat and then they
come and tell me Well by Nature our men
are not me yeah babes then you should
have known that you should not be in a
yeah a caveat though I think most of the
modern men don't want a second wife they
want a side piece so they want to remain
monogamous to the one that they love but
they have the local news
you know what's crazy that there are
women who want open relationships too so
you just have to find that for me but
for me I have an issue with dishonesty
when you when a woman communicates to
you and lets you know that she just
wants she wants to monogamy and you say
I want that too but then that's not the
reality of what you're living because
there are women there's there's somebody
for everybody so if you want if you want
to be with someone and you don't want to
be tied down I think women are in a
different age now where a lot of women
don't actually want to be tied down too
so you can easily find that but I think
that women aren't honest with ourselves
and like kind of lie because
I'm sorry A lot of times girls will date
a guy and they know he's a cheater yeah
they know he gets girls it's like what
did you think would happen even even
there's a lot of women that entertain
men that are in relationships or yeah
married or even you know there's there
was a guy that actually like he's he
speaks on uh polygamy well polygeny so
the man being able to have multiple not
women and um so he recently sort of
messaged me about you know would I
insane him and I said does your person
know
you know that's your status and he was
like no I said why would I intern a man
who speaks about it but isn't practicing
it do you get what I mean like if you
come correct that's something I can
consider if it's a part of my lifestyle
but if you're gonna lie then lie like
why would I be entertaining that also
that's not really Genie if your partner
is not aware
they are very aware of their position
they're very aware that there's
otherwise there's other girlfriends
stuff like that exactly sir you're
cheating yeah exactly do you think if we
accept cheating the first time you're
basically saying it's okay no the rest
yeah yes because I feel like if you you
accept it the first time and you said
okay you can cheat and I will stay then
why would he not do it again but I feel
like a man will cheat regardless whether
you stay or you don't because you could
be then technically single and you will
go back and forth with him for months or
years now
I think that I don't think staying the
first time will enable like will mean he
can carry on doing he's going to get
away with that I think that people are
first of all people are humans I think
that when we get in relationships we
have this idea of like ownership with
people and I think that is I think
that's a that's not a good thing so
people are humans humans make mistakes
and I think sometimes as well
unfortunately some people don't know
what they have until you're at the point
of kind of losing it and there are some
men who they cheat one time and they
realize that actually that why did I do
that kind of like that doesn't I could
lose they realize what they have and
they what they could lose and so it kind
of it change that they don't cheat again
I know I've been like that by the same
time even two years you'll do the same
thing again I didn't believe that
because I know real life men who have
cheated once I don't know
they get better right 50 years if you
want to be like married long term 50
years is a long time people are their
habits
feel like men cheat more when you tell
them not to or when you put pressure for
them to have to be monogamous
when women talk about Alpha about oh
those are not the men that we like well
the two men that cheated on me I want to
call them I made them the alpha period
so they weren't somebody that those
Ordinary People one was really obese it
wasn't like anybody that anybody else
would want
so I've made them the alpha so as far as
I'm concerned if a man's gonna cheat
they're gonna cheat that is a word
because everybody's learned about this
Alpha you can get a man that's like an
ordinary everyday man like what they
were and according to how you are as a
woman you make them your Alpha so nobody
was looking at them as an alpha you know
it's some guys here and that that is
such a word because some guys are not
what Society what a lot of women see as
desirable but I think I think there's
something in menu that when a woman
likes them
they just think oh I feel like it makes
them feel like
yeah and so then they start walking in
that spirit and then they think I can do
anything I want to do no but wait what
you're basically saying is that you
understand why men behave the way to
behave but you still get angry at the
way they behave because
honesty no because think about this way
yeah and this is where societies geared
towards women like men have to sacrifice
what they have to do naturally to
conform to what a woman wants a man
wants to spread his seed that's what
he's driven to do so no that's what he's
driven to do so I always say that men
should have practice discipline I've
done so myself because I know it's
important to successful monogamous
relationships however because women are
given sex like you're born of value in
terms of the sexual Marketplace a man
has to earn his right to have sex so
when he sees an opportunity he's gonna
take it more time as if he lacks
discipline and can I just say
that I believe that most of the time
it's nobody wants these men until he's
got a woman yeah seriously
and it's not like the women don't know
oh he's got he's got he's got a woman
if he didn't have a woman I don't think
that they would want that man but it's
just that they always want a man that
somebody else is God yeah that just
makes it easy for the men to cheat yeah
it's pre-selection like so historically
like we wanted men that got other women
because it was a sign that he could take
care of us too if he could take care of
them and that's the thing coming back to
Eddie's point I think what Society
doesn't realize is that men don't have
to cheat if you want multiple partners
that you're going to be responsible for
which I think is possible you need to be
honest and do it but it's this whole
okay I can jump from this girl to this
yeah
I don't think I don't think most men
want two wives That's like two headaches
behaved there's nothing worse than
having two of you in one place no this
is this is the problem with men you
don't want it because you can't handle
it but then you don't want to be
monogamous if you can't monogamous be
single don't be with one word
why would they why would they have to
why would they like I mean I'm sorry if
you're in the top 10 20 of guys they
don't have to just be single they can
have them
when they can get a girlfriend cheat on
her and we just talk to the panel y'all
stay no no but this is perfect
this is the problem it's not that it's
not that you need to have a girlfriend
and cheat on you have a girlfriend and
tell her I'm not monogamous so if you
want to be with me and I give you these
perks yeah but why would he do that when
he can just cheat on you and y'all but
this isn't but then when you get the
toxic behavior from her don't moan when
she then vandalizes your whole property
okay why why do we why do we put our bad
decisions on to men okay isn't that like
you're just toxic because it's because I
like I've I've been cheated on before it
wasn't it wasn't fun but I never did
anything toxic or crazy or any any of
the [ __ ] that I hear girls say that
that's a you that's a you problem no man
no man can make you do crazy you're
either crazy or you're not no do you
know what it is for me personally I
don't call it crazy things I just [ __ ] I
call it disrespect and reacting to
disrespect okay for example I feel like
when a woman doesn't react and a man
cheats and he gets away with it he
doesn't learn that this has hurt or
impacted someone when a woman then
reacts he has to either have discussions
with her or he needs to realize right
this was a repossession of it okay but
but in these situations everyone reacted
and on the couch
I'm saying even you reacted you were
going through his phone you were telling
him like whatever and and like looking
at his messages or I can't remember
exactly how you said you found out so
you did react he didn't learn his lesson
because he had like a million side
pieces no no no but he never
confirmed that he cheated or anything
but that's what I'm saying and my
reactions were they yeah when I first
left when I left when I first got the
okay this must be confirmation because
obviously all the guy cells yeah I
reacted to that yeah and he was like I
can't tolerate this cool and then I left
him but then he did write me letters
saying he wants me back I never went
back sorry I just want to say yeah I
don't think I don't think you
necessarily need to react because I know
you made a point about reacting for him
to understand that this is wrong because
I don't react like the way you react I
think that's this is how I react to
things if you do something that's wild
that's crazy disrespectful to me I'm
sorry cool that's what you've done and I
keep it moving so with me in my
situation I did I didn't react I let you
know that okay this is what you did this
is not on it's not something I want to
stand for and I kept it moving and years
later he still wanting to have me back
yeah but I don't think you need to
necessarily react to get to let a guy
understand what he's doing wrong yeah
and I also I agree what you said earlier
where you said how because I think I
hear a lot of women sometimes say stuff
like oh he made me crazy
you're either you're either crazy or
you're not okay
no so my point is I would never refer to
it as a woman reacting to it however she
reacts for me I wouldn't say it's crazy
because I feel like Society say oh it's
crazy that's her reaction that's crazy
no but what exactly I'm saying it's her
expressing her emotions and she's
enraged and racist
you're not okay you guys wait you're not
you're not a child you're a grown adult
I'm sorry can you just stop stop
interrupting me you're not a child
you're a grown adult if you make if you
do something crazy you're crazy you
can't blame it on other people like
nobody can make you do anything like
that that's that's like what a child
would say I think can I can I just
haven't really spoken but I just want to
say an observation that I've made in
this conversation so the younger ladies
have proven a point which I don't know
if anyone's noticed they looked for a
problem they wound themselves up Auntie
said she experienced a similar thing but
she didn't wind herself up she responded
to the situation as the situation
happened happened and she didn't go in
there like I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
do that I didn't go looking for it like
you said yeah so the difference is
within the modern women
we're looking for the problem and when
we amp ourselves up in the situation
we're actually reacting before we get to
the point where we're with the man so
we're already angry and because there's
so much on social media and so much
access to different women at the same
time
we're literally winding ourselves up if
you look for it you're gonna find it we
know that and your responsibility yeah
and exactly and that's what it does it
shows your maturity level and your um
emotional management so you know like at
work if someone pisses you off you know
how to manage it you know you're not
just going to flip out and start Carson
because you don't want to lose your job
that's your livelihood but in this
situation you haven't really calculated
how you're going to manage the situation
you've just reacted and I think as a
younger woman like in this generation
we're very reactionary to what's going
on around us rather than
um sorry grounding ourselves first and
then having like a clear fool and and
then responding you know I think I could
actually get older you take a break
realize that though like everyone's
gonna yeah it's a waste it's a waste of
energy it's literally a waste of energy
I remember being like 14 and finding out
you know someone's cheating and you
would go absolutely mad at them and
you'd cry and you know you'd get really
angry and then as you get older like you
said you'd realize you just you know
yeah if you're gonna do it fine cool
I'll leave you do whatever you want
there's no point in wasting your energy
when you're not going to get anything
back from anyway because I think women
need to understand that and again I'm
not advocate for it Bob in most
instances men will be men
so all this angle all this blowing up it
doesn't it doesn't affect no one but you
because like you said
women seem to think that by getting
angry the guy's gonna change or he's
gonna see it differently he's probably
still going to do the same thing just
so it's like is that when when do women
come to the realization that
that's how they're built you're built
different because what and this is what
I've seen before is that there's two
lenses there's your lens and there's the
Mel lens but you're only see things
through your lens so how you perceive
sex is how you think men to see sex and
it's completely different and what I'd
like to know is after you found out and
you went back how is your behavior
towards him after that it wasn't
you trust them again or was you always
watching him or was done his phone
irritating him or was having a dig but I
think that's the end of the relationship
anyway
no point like yeah there's no point
because
if there's no point
you know there's no point but you're
continuing relationship I think I think
women that stay it's not because they
want to continue I think it's the
emotions of love and having to like
grieve the relationship while they're
there and I think eventually they get
over it I don't think they go back it's
the one team that they're in you don't
want to you don't want to get rid of the
routine but then also you have women
that will break up with guys in their
head before they've broke up with them
yeah exactly and then when you leave
it's not as hard but within a caveat
today is that look if if if we're gonna
go off the pretense that most men behave
this way and the men that you're
attracted to are in a small like
percentage of men who will do the same
thing anyway doesn't it make more sense
to stay
with the devil that you know then seek
something else new outside
because you know or you can be allow
yourself
[Music]
you allow yourself to feel that pain
then you can move through it and past it
when you sit on it or you go back you
have it there like you're waiting for
something you're anticipating another
cheating you don't feel the pain you're
not going to feel happiness yeah you
don't move through it and I think when
one once a man cheats especially with
like social media and all these things
um we have these experiences and then
we're anticipating something going wrong
and then we kind of provoke it to happen
if we don't work with it like together
as a couple then it's not gonna work
nothing there's no communication in that
I think some women weigh up their wrists
and the rewards because I've I don't
think I'm I always say here that if your
partner cheats on you yeah if you're
going to stay
then you need to be staying to move
forward I don't believe in staying with
someone and every chance you get yeah
why are you here
you make my life miserable but I also
think that there are women as well who
weigh up the realities of life I feel
like with a lot a lot of what a lot of
people think about love it's very um
fairy tale it's very yeah it's wishful
thinking but the realities of life is
that I'm at this age for example we've
been married blah blah blah you've
cheated this is one this is the one time
I've caught you cheating blah blah yeah
what am I going to lose if I walk away
from this
and what's really out there so I think
some some women have to
they just work through it they think
that you know I can't bother to do all
of this again I'm gonna have to find
somebody I'm gonna have to be single go
for a divorce yeah or break up and then
I've spent I have this much time I've
invested so much time in this
relationship you know let's just let me
forget let's forgive it and let's move
forward and do whatever it is that we
need to do to come to understanding that
this can't happen again yeah and I think
I don't I don't see anything wrong with
that I think that's enough rules
if you listen to what they're saying
they actually stay and plan to leave
yeah men just leave women always stay
and plan to leave that's why women get
divorced they lose so much because the
women have been planning it yeah very
few times it they cheat and then you
actually get past it and have a happy
life what I'd like to know is I think I
think that people used to get past it
all the time I think modern women can't
because we've been sold a bill of goods
that men can't live up to and we're told
that he has to be taller than us make
money like be basically Prince Charming
and not cheat on you but it's like if
you want a guy on a certain level he's
probably gonna cheat
I think that women romanticize love too
much realistically love is something
that transforms every day when you're
working on it and if you're not working
on it with your partner then it's not
love if you're going to look at love as
a romantic thing so kind gestures every
day your mind's going to be considerate
to you every day it's gonna be in your
favor
you have that mentality of entitlement
just because you're in the relationship
and I think from like my experience of
observation men get tired of that
because what's the benefits to them you
know you want more no matter how much
they give It's never enough and then
once they've given the Max Capacity they
can go to somebody else who wants much
less and is happy with that and they're
not going to cause aggravation you find
out about it and then you kick off so it
kind of undoes all the work that's been
put into the relationship on his side
then he loses everything and then like
what's the benefit that's why it should
always be 50 50. so the guy puts in the
energy you know he's being considerate a
fetching the flowers and stuff like that
but then there's no flowers
still do it but then like the girl needs
to give the energy it's about gratitude
it's about gratitude and reciprocity
you deserve to be courted because we're
not we're not young and we're not pure
anymore yeah I I would say no because
we're not pure anymore like what's pure
yeah so it's all moving forward and
forwards yeah but I definitely think
there should be some level of the basic
respect from that today you know it's
not just like oh we'll text and then
we'll meet up and then like we'll have
sex and then that's kind of it you know
you should really get to know each other
and make sure that you're both on the
same level and if he makes the energy
you make the energy if he doesn't make
the energy just say okay I'll go make
the energy with someone else
that's when the women that got cheated
on how did you feel did you take it
personally
because I think you might have taken it
more personally than he did
but how did it make you feel knowing
that he cheated it is personal it was
with me the problem was I came from a
polygamous household so my dad had two
wives and he's got 14 kids so my mum has
nine my dad had my other mum has five so
I've come from a very
um honest and transparent relationship
the reason I felt disrespected is
because this person obviously didn't
want to tell me even till this day he
would lie right now the reason that I'm
single I'm not actively searching is
because no man is honest and will say to
me actually I am I do want multiple
women because when I asked them they
will just say no I'm cool and if they
did say like if they said it I'll
respect it would you be with them though
100 way more but you know what you have
to remember in this situation you're the
exception to the rule because women
often fall in love what they hear not a
mental level that's the thing I think
I'm still quite a traditional woman so I
I don't I haven't done the dating scene
traditional women get married before the
age of 25. I was married I am well
that's my traditional women don't get
divorced well you can't be you can't be
a traditional no no I'm I'm not divorced
yet so I'm not divorced yet so I thought
you said you were single well um It's
Complicated so I'm not compost yet okay
I'm separated but obviously the reason
why I like
um like Esther said the reason why I'm
not pushing for the divorce or whatever
is because in within my situation I'm
weighing out what's beneficial to me if
it's better for me to stay or better for
me to be ending up in the streets and in
the Streets of London it's not for me
it's the ghetto girls
why do you want to leave because it was
he the one that cheated no no so this
with my within my marriage what happened
is we were a lot younger and because I
was conforming to like just say the
Western ideologies and social media yeah
put a big pressure on what I expected
from the relationship so I wanted like
you said flowers and all of this and
blah blah and I put importance on that
instead of me actually looking and
growing with the person and you know
figuring out our own lives and we were a
lot younger he obviously wasn't where he
wanted to be and I think it just put a
lot of strain on us so we have separated
but it for me
give it I probably will end up back with
him just because it's it wasn't a toxic
relationship it was a good relationship
we just weren't the right people so do
you think women by that women leave nice
guys because you stayed with the guy who
cheated but the guy who didn't stay with
the guy who cheated because I didn't
know for sure
okay even with that situation again that
was like my first pull-on relationship
because we're obviously I am also
religious like I do believe in God yeah
and I and I believe fornication is a sin
so with me if it's a big thing for me to
even try fornicate I'd rather not
um in that first relationship I was
staying with him because my intention
was marriage and we were planning to get
married right and it was a lot more
secure yeah
wouldn't it be more secure in the second
because you are married well no that's
what I mean so the second one it
happened Okay the reason why I'm not
leaving is because
he's it's not that he's he's uh he's not
a uh he's a good and or amazing guy it's
more it was a it's the right person
wrong time so why how do you know it's
going to work in three years time why
the three years because it sounds like
you've got it all figured out now that
you know what a great guy he is and if
you both need to work on it sounds like
a backup plan yeah because why the three
years I don't think I don't think it's I
don't think he's an amazing guy I think
with time he will also it I feel like we
need time to figure ourselves out and
when I say that I mean I feel like he's
not ready to I feel like a man a man's
under a lot of pressure he feels like he
has to have X amount of money he needs
to make sure he can keep a woman because
I feel like men feel like women will
cheat on them if they're not doing
certain things and I think he feels like
if he doesn't provide me with a million
roses and all of that I'm not going to
stay loyal to him he doesn't realize
that I'm a religious person that's not
going to be a problem
if that makes sense I just think that
you need to get it sooner or later
another conversation because you can
both work it out together and grow
together rather than three years time
you could you you can both be in
separate places in three years yeah you
might as well do it together you know
what you want you sound like you know
what you want you sound quite sensible
and reasonable so why not do it now and
see where you both are in three years
rather than wait for years as to jump in
because there's a lot that can happen in
for you well you can get there together
you know he's not there yet you know
what he needs and you can be there to
support him and I think that's such I'm
so sorry I think there's certain things
that you need to work I get where you're
coming from I think this because you
guys got married when you were younger I
think there's certain things where you
have to work on by yourself to then be
able to come together with someone so I
get the three years thing because
clearly you've got stuff that you want
to work on and growing whatever and he's
got his own issues and I think if you
guys get back you guys get back together
that precious we're going to be there
because you haven't worked on your
individual selves that's why I always
say even with marriages and because I
decided to get married and stuff but I
know that I'm not ready to get married
now because the stuff that I need to
figure out and these are things I need
to figure out by myself before I can
then come together to figure out that to
figure that that part of my life out to
get me yeah I still think you want to go
Carnival that's right
I want to hear that you're figuring
yourself out they just think you're
sleeping yeah
and honestly that's what it sounds like
because I don't understand what do you
how it's not that can I ask you can I
ask you how how long it's been since you
both separated like how long have you
been figuring it out
um I'll say it was the start of the
pandemic but it's not that we're
figuring it out I think it was just that
we were two different people coming
together and the pressures of the
pandemic obviously put a lot more strain
on us and I feel like also this concept
like for example
we people believe that if you're married
you have to sleep in the same bed every
single night whereas some people's
relationships aren't like that I didn't
understand that when I was younger that
actually some people genuinely don't
want to be in a bed with someone else
every single night and that's something
that I'm only coming to terms with now
if that makes sense so I think more the
more that I'm growing as a person I'm
learning a lot about myself and I'm
accepting as well that you don't have to
have what social media show as a as a
traditional marriage you can have your
own version yeah can I ask you a
question though do you think you and
your partner have the same core values
yes and I think that's the only reason
why we're I can see me being compatible
with him because so what's like the real
like I don't understand what what's not
there then it seems like he's a great
guy yeah
I think I think no no I think it's not
that he's a great guy it's I've made a
choice and I feel like I will do
whatever I can to make sure it works
okay if that makes sense because I think
especially with marriage it's a big
commitment and you know you do it
through thick and thin yeah um I think
it's more
um I didn't understand like when he did
mention if he did mention multiple
partners or having other partners for me
that was like what do you mean but I
then had to like recheck myself and
actually say that's not something I'm
not used to or I'm abnormal or that
isn't the norm
um so I think when I initially reacted
and again that was the trauma from the
first relationship coming through that I
had to unlearn it was almost like oh
that means you must be cheating every
day when actually he wasn't so it made
us very toxic for no reason so it kind
of goes back to like women can't handle
the truth well I've separated and like
revisiting what I actually want in life
and how it impacts me I've realized that
actually it's not I can't handle the to
mature if that makes sense then I
wouldn't be able to but as I've now
learned a lot more about myself I'm like
yeah have you had help for your trauma I
guess it was more professional help yeah
well I've done I've done counseling it's
not uh I would yeah I've done counseling
and stuff I don't think I think it's
just time so sometimes you don't even
cancel doesn't help it's just just
maturity I think it's more reason about
emotional management yeah in your
emotions
um in line with what's going on because
often we we have emotional responses to
things that are happening at that time
yeah we've thought about them we've
we've and I'm and I know someone's gonna
say oh you're Matt you're saying we're
no we think about things that could
happen we think about those things think
about it and the moment we're confronted
with the situation at hand we respond to
the
because of your background I think
you're quite sensible in it but what I
would say is that for most women the way
you're handling it wouldn't be good
advice because for most women taking
time away and pushing it to the Future
just means racking up bodies racking up
more trauma and expecting a guy to come
and take hold of it in the in in the
future and I think that's where like
obviously like my faith comes in if that
makes sense because obviously that's
what will keep me in check in that sense
because I I don't believe in sort of
committing fornication like that to me
it protects me a bit more from that
um obviously women who might not share
my same background might be a bit yeah
maybe they might you know because yeah
them hidden is is taking more Willy yeah
but but are you actually this is the
question I would ask is are you actually
dealing with the issues at hand because
so so you're working on them separately
but you're not working on them together
and that issue so when you come back
you're going to be a different woman and
he's going to be a different man and
then there's going to be other issues
because you're not working to together
so I think what's happening is I'm
growing into who I am and he's growing
into who he is and if it matches this is
why I say I give it time because if it
is that we work out we work out if not
we're just getting better at just say
like because I've got a five year old
we're getting better at co-parenting
yeah I mean so we've got it we're we're
getting better in our relationships
what's the separation his choice or
yours
it was
I guess are both come on someone someone
started the conversation it wasn't who
started this way it wasn't a nice
separation yeah it was very it was a
very
um abrupt and sort of not great yeah but
who who started the cut like someone
it's dishonest to say that it was a
mutual thing
like someone has to start the
conversation
um someone else to say this isn't moving
out or I'm moving out or we're
this isn't working let's take some time
I guess the guy would he would say it
more than I would but then it's
it's more because I would uh yeah I
guess he would say it so you say it
argument so yeah so is his choice yeah
okay yeah that's abnormal usually it's
like the other way around yeah no no I
guess it was his choice but it's more I
think um obviously where we had a child
involved it was a lot harder
um because we couldn't get the right
grieving or time apart that we would
have had to because it's almost like we
had an argument the day before and then
because of my daughter we'll have to now
stay in communication
um I think the time the covert time
really helped sort of put that aside do
you think like if you called him
tomorrow and said like I want to work
this out let's move back in together he
would do it not yet not yet I think and
he's also agreed in a few years
potentially it's more likely whereas I
think he isn't where he wants to be and
he knows that I'm not where I want to be
and I think one of the biggest things
because when we did break up I never had
a hot girl summer let's say like I've
never experienced that I came from a
culture where we didn't really go back
I'm not trying to be rude yeah but
didn't you just say you're at carnival
before
so I never really experienced and I've
experienced that sort of date in or
casual dating or even like you know so
when I first came out of the Pan um the
relationship I was like okay yeah let me
explore this I tried online yeah I tried
online dating it was horrendous I tried
you know
meeting people in my life it was it was
a joke so yeah like I now get to go
Carnival as a single person I guess with
my friends but again it's not it's just
for fun for me it's nothing like nothing
there's no guys
it's not serious for you but if you're
looking at it from a male perspective
these are all the flags that say okay
she doesn't want to do this no but it's
not I don't go Carnival too
it's inevitable like even if you try not
to you could be standing a guy once yeah
yeah remove him you know
understand but it's inevitable because
it's you know when you're in a
relationship and there's things that is
you know you're me well okay let me put
it like this as from a male specific
perspective and I'm not a male but look
at it like this you're making yourself
available for men to uh yeah and and
it's kind of like your words really
aren't matching what you're saying
because like you said you're a
traditional woman traditional women
don't go to Carnival
let me let me finish like my mom my
grandma wouldn't be caught dead at
carnival they said they want Vibes
they're like what are you talking about
I think
like it's on insult it's just like you
can't be I think people are mistaken
what Carnival's about because obviously
Carnival yeah it's a Vibe it's small
food maybe maybe at one point but I'm
sorry you cannot convince me that it's
completely cultural when there's girls
with their asses twerking I'm sorry
there's people having sex on the street
you cannot convince that this is but I
think what the I think what initially
Carnival was wasn't this like even this
dagger dagga dagger like so that's a
part of their culture let's say I it's
not me that's going to be getting better
I've done Carnival I've taken part and
all I've had costumes in England and in
Barbados and the safest place if you
want to go as a woman and it's to be
inside the band yeah where you're safe
not to be out in the crowd not to be out
in the crowd and I don't understand when
people go and they say oh we if you want
to go on experience gonna go on Sunday
children's day yeah yeah let's just go
on a Sunday but no decent woman's gonna
go on a Monday and um I was listening to
what you're saying and
everything felt alright until you said
you had a child
for me personally because I just think
to myself marriage is a hard work yes
marriage is a hard work and I think if
you've got a child to say like oh I need
to we need to go and find ourselves to
me it just seems like everything's just
going backwards yeah like you're finding
that like you got married first rather
than find out about each other then get
married have the child all I'm thinking
about is yeah you might be great
co-parents but I'm thinking of myself is
marriage is hard work yeah it is and to
say like I'm going to come back and
revisit it in another five years to me
that's just me personally it sounds
weird yeah
especially as your traditional are you
supposed to work at it no like I said it
wasn't my choice that wasn't my choice
so obviously it's not my choice that he
feels like he's not ready to commit into
that role again and that's what I mean
but you married him and that's what I
was saying that it seems weird because
you married him and they never like
you're starting
backwards so what I'm saying is
obviously in my situation I could try
find a new partner or husband or
whatever to marry it's just this country
I don't think is it enables that does
that make sense everyone's everyone's
trying to be City girl or city life and
that doesn't it's not something that I
would do so I feel like in this culture
in this Society I'm not going to find
the man I want to marry and when I say
three years I say three four years you
could be even next year whatever but
it's more if he's ready when he's ready
where he is I might be at the stage
where we're ready to work out again yeah
because that's what I find interesting
you know also can I just sorry for
cancer I just wanted to add like
listening to the whole story like Auntie
said it's it's like it's worked
backwards So within everything you've
said not once have I heard anything
about like your child how this impacts
your child and I'm not judging you for
that but that child has to live through
it and how does that
she doesn't know that we're separated
well I don't know but but the thing is
the thing is that's an assumption as
your daughter grit gets older she will
notice little things she will ask
questions and I think a lot of
relationship breakdowns don't ever
consider the children the children the
children don't choose to be here we
bring them here as adults and part of
being an adult is being responsible and
part of being responsible is making good
choices and making informed decisions
about the things that we do so I'm not
saying like your relationship is this or
that but what I am saying is a lot of
the time
um
children are kind of pushed to the side
and it's me me me me me even within the
partnership that's why it doesn't work
because everybody's thinking about
themselves finding themselves doing
their thing
um you know exploring themselves
whatever
children are growing up in fragmented
families and then they have no Direction
no they might have a foundation but they
don't have any direction yeah
I think I think
it feels as if like we're putting their
ownness just on her so her not what her
saying sorry not her so it's Soraya
saying that she wants to that the time
apart is needed yeah he also feels the
exact same thing that she's feeling so
he also needs to take time about I do
honest I do think that a lot of people
sometimes get into relationships and
they've got like a a me mindset and that
will not help relationships yeah but I
really believe that there are certain
things you need to work on on your own
yeah before you can then be in you can
then come together with someone and
build a healthy relationships
sorry let me yeah let's finish for
example yeah say like say for example
say you've got like the things you've
been through previous Partners or
whatever if you do not work on that on
your own yeah you're going to enter a
new relationship and you're going to
bring up all that baggage into this new
situation it doesn't help you it doesn't
help the child I don't like when people
think that you yes children are
important yes you do whatever works for
your child but I have friends who've
grown up where their moms have stayed
with the dads Because they stay for the
kids and the kids have grown up and said
you know I wish you left that because
because you could have gone and been at
home you could have been a healthy a
woman who sorted out sorted out her life
it's usually I've been in a bit it's
usually because my mom the mom talks too
much to the kids you shouldn't know
about yourself
the moms no I see this again and again
and again like moms moms will demonize
the dad and like talk [ __ ] about the dad
and then and then say oh you should have
like why does a kid know that I did not
know that I just said that the second
and the second and the second thing is I
I don't know her marriage I'm not saying
it's not his fault too I said but I said
the marriage yeah but I'm saying like
like for both people like if you have a
kid involved like what you need to
figure out yourself figure it out in one
Under One Roof no but I disagree I
disagree with that because I have again
out this is what I'm saying is stuff
that conversation I've had with people
who have actually been in these in these
real life situations I know I have
friends whose mums literally did not let
them know what's their dad what piece of
[ __ ] the dad was they grew up to see
what a disappointment their father was
and they were like their mum to know why
would she left I think that yes people
are important I think that it's I think
that yes you know you should create the
best environment for your child and blah
blah blah all that is great absolutely
yes cool whatever but sometimes being in
the same household is not the best
environment for your child
every single statistical disadvantage
they're more likely to run away from
home they're more likely to drop out of
school they're more likely to be
homeless they're more likely to end up
in prison there's a direct correlation
between single parent homes and going to
prison
so you can you can you can say okay okay
you know there are certain situations
that are exceptions sure but if there's
not abuse there's not cheating
why are you why are you doing that to
your kid I'm supposed to put your kid
first go ahead how many parents from the
panel
well I just wanted to say this as well
um to go back to what you said when you
said no people you've spoken to have
said
now I wish you had left that or whatever
I wish you would expect it yeah or
separated but that means that there were
things that were going on yeah that they
could see and feel an experience now how
do they know what it would have been
like without having their dad in the
household I think it's fair for children
to grow up to make their own decisions
about especially their fathers because I
feel in society as women we make a lot
of decisions for our children based on
how we feel at the time and we put our
children at a disadvantage
and I think for myself I always say this
but my dad
the things that he's done for me I'm not
saying oh that's a perfect my dad's not
a perfect man but there's things my dad
has done for me that have given me
strength inner strength that I can't
explain to you I can only show you the
way that I operate
um so for you to say like they've said
why I can't why didn't you leave dad
there must have been something in the
household that they were experiencing my
mum would always tell me as a basic rule
when you're raising kids they never see
anything that goes on whether it's
decision making whether it's fighting
nothing happens in front of the kids and
I brought this point up before when I
talked about women having or losing
their power because a lot of women want
to be at the Forefront of relationships
now where they dictate things my mom
said a lot of the decisions made in the
household my dad looked like he was
making the decision when really she had
a lot of influence on how the decision
was made that's not because that she
wanted to be at the front is because she
knew how to play her role in that
relationship when my parents did fight
it was never in front of us because what
would happen is that kids are
opportunists they're going to have
favorites if you see your mum fighting
your dad most kids will gravitate to
their mum your dad naturally becomes a
demon in that in that kid's eyes so
parents show too much and women again
like Paul said love to talk a lot they
all start saying he's doing this and
then you and the kid become best friends
and start talking about secrets in the
relationship how the hell is that kid
not going to grow up thinking the
devil's a piece of [ __ ] when the mom
vocalized every single problem she had
like the way she would to her best
friends
I like that though but I also said that
the situations that I cases that I know
cases where the parents that they didn't
know they grew up to know what had
happened in the house yeah grew up they
got there that's the important thing
about my thing is still that I still
maintain the fact that there are things
that you need to work on by yourself
that you cannot do in a relationship and
I think that each person each family is
a case-by-case situation every not every
child it's not a universal law or
Universal rules or rulebook of how to
raise children and so if in any
situation you feel like you know what
the best thing for this child knowing
how my child is having emotion my
channels or whatever it is the best
thing for my child is that we go as we
go our sufferers and we can be healthy
parents and it's a healthy father for
the child itself
don't you think it's more mature to say
um I'm gonna figure out how to get along
with a man before before just breaking
up
the question was your child's life ever
in danger no no
I think as far as the way I'm seeing
this okay let me you sounded I'm not
saying it's just you I'm saying that
both of you should have worked on it
okay let me let me clarify that like
what you're saying about I I won't say
that my sons my son's dad was abusive I
never ever said anything bad about my
son's dad I remember and you see lots of
people oh you're just like your father I
remember being in the supermarket with
my son and he was missing about and I
said to him
do you know what you're just like your
mother you're just like your mother I
don't know why I brought you out and
this woman stopped and said oh um if his
mother was there you know you shouldn't
be talking to him like that and he
looked at me and I looked and I started
laughing because I have never ever said
to him you're just like your father and
sometimes people sit there and they
don't realize that
this sign language there's body language
there's feelings children will pick up
these things some people need to be a
part but by what you're saying and how
religious you are and the fact that you
are married and the fact that you both
know that you need to grow and the fact
that you know the child's life wasn't in
danger the way I'm saying is that what
have separate rooms have separate rooms
in the same house and work out your
differences because at least the child
if you are adult enough to come this far
and when you talk about the trauma from
the previous relationship that's why
Oscar has she had treatment for a trauma
rather than pass it on so you're gonna
get back together with your husband
you're not going to have this Trauma
from previous relationship and you're
quite vocal and one thing that you said
that I haven't seen you say you're going
to do is like come off social media
don't be influenced by it no it sounds
like social media had a big part of it
and the way you thought marriages should
be so now you know marriages are not
like that then no so okay let me just
clarify I think there's a lot of spec
calculations or something so yeah so
when I initially uh
okay so before I got pregnant let's say
oh no actually yeah before I got
pregnant is when we first had
conversations about him feeling like he
settled down a bit too young right now
that gave me red flags in the sense that
I felt like that to me meant he wants to
be out on the streets does that make
sense so when I say I didn't I didn't I
took that trauma in that was the first
initial uh year of meeting him let's say
and all of that it that sort of came in
it's only when I got pregnant
and then
um I said to him like even then I found
it quite hard to swallow assuming that
he might want other women because at
that point even though I came from
polygenous household I couldn't accept
my man being with other women and that's
when I say social media impacted me
where it said it to me especially them
times it was like oh men can't cheat if
men cheat their trash leave them all of
that blah blah right so obviously when I
after my daughter was born
couple of years later it we Revisited it
but it wasn't in the sense that oh I'm
going to be with other women it was more
him expressing that what if he can't
stay faithful to one person for the rest
of his life now to me again I was still
young I was only like 24 25 at that time
for me again it was like what do you
mean that means you're going to cheat
right to tear so it's almost like okay
fine if you're gonna cheat then I don't
want to be with you so we separated
because for me I couldn't swallow the
fact that he might in the future want to
be so cool so you left I thought you
said no so well the relationship up to
the point where we were arguing or I was
being toxic or unhappy so he was like I
can't do this right so obviously we
separated after we separated cool we've
done our we've gone our separate way
again when I say finding myself I'm not
talking about exploring other people or
bodies I'm talking about revisiting what
who I am and my course well and I
understand that but like when you you
were talking talking about earlier
because a lot of the things we're saying
we're just saying what you said back to
you so like earlier you said you did the
dating apps you you were going on dates
you went to Carnival and like that that
sounds like and I think that's where
again a lot of my like the society will
impact you because again people in my
ear oh you're young you're this girl why
not date I had to then ask myself I've
got a child I could date another guy is
he going to treat my child the same as
her dad is he gonna love me is he not
going to cheat on me and then I have to
say actually I can't guarantee that so
that's why I haven't dated or moved on
thank you
so like you so how old your child five
six and only six so you're you're not
going to be with the dad you think okay
I'm gonna start dating another guy you
would at least wait you know a good year
before you know they're really in the
child's life I have two children
um and obviously I'm not not with the
dad and whatever
um and I've had like uh maybe I've dated
one guy since didn't meet my kids didn't
speak to my kids like he knew their
names that was it because I'm not gonna
fetch a guy into their life just to be
temporary so I think when when you speak
like that you you do need to know that
they're going to be there but even that
so for me I again I date with intention
but even that deal with intention is
still very different in my culture
because in my culture we get married
very quick to meeting people like I'm
not in that culture but I I do I date to
marry that's what I personally would
like to do
um you know I wouldn't have chosen to
have kids this young if I'd planned it
and obviously I don't regret them but I
would still try to be as traditional as
I could
um but I think it is it's harder in this
generation and you've just got to be a
lot more careful
I had my son at 17.
that made me grow up yeah so I had my
dad I wasn't it wasn't that I was going
to say oh I was too young you know
[ __ ] happens you do with it just get on
with it and not wanted I think to myself
yeah I'm a single parent I'm gonna start
dating didn't think about that at all it
was just concentrate on my child I
didn't think consider dating at all but
that's what I'm saying that's what I did
yeah that's what I'm doing yeah like I'm
not considering dating that I said I'm
not even mingling with people I'm not
intending if if I met someone and I
thought organically and I thought oh my
God they blow my mind that's one thing
you're not looking for you well it's
just okay when you say that and then
earlier you said you were on dating apps
it kind of it it was just the initial
breakup obviously when you're in your
feelings and you're broken up and my
friends are like oh you're single
because I haven't ever been to school
yeah it was the first time I'm single
and women our age were all dating at
that time 25 26. they were all trying to
date not even with kids there's a lot of
single mums trying to do it in in our
with my modern women but again that's
again what I had to revisit I had to say
to myself am I going to find a man who's
not going to treat me yeah but you see
like how it sounds when you say it like
your story like keeps contradicting
itself like it like I haven't even
really asked you like like you've been
going on like talking about it and like
volunteering this information and then
like you keep contradicting yourself and
I think the reason is is because I am a
clash of cultures so I am very you know
obviously I'm Bangladeshi British Muslim
and I think the modern side is what is
me what I'm fighting against does that
make sense so the more I'm realizing
actually I'm not this model woman is the
more comfortable I'm getting in who I am
I don't I don't think you can really go
back like I I don't think you can really
claim traditional if you're separated
from your like your husband it's no when
I say traditional I say traditionally my
values in my models not that I'm I'm I'm
gonna stick in a marriage that I'm
unhappy in because I'm a traditional
woman it's more I know what I want for
myself and I know that this right but
like that rhetoric right there that
sounds very modern what can I just say
again all I'm hearing is I I I I I I'm
not and I'm not trying to personalize it
to you just that you're speaking and a
lot of the things that have been said
today are eye base and in relationships
in marriage it's about partnership
working together and we're not nobody's
perfect sometimes sometimes you make
mistakes and you have to work through it
and we've I'm not married I've never
been married and I think it's easy for
me to talk on it you know from a
perspective but when you've got
a child involved your feelings involved
you know finances involved whatever it
might be work involved your friends
involved you you have to kind of peel
back on all of the factors that
influence you and look at the bare bones
of the relationship which is you your
child and your partner and literally
Zone in on that and make that your
priority wait I've got a question I've
got a question quickly just to kind of
caveat of it yeah yeah so on that note
because you're talking about I I do
would you say that the Modern Woman is
selfish then yes because it because
society allows that to be the case
because it's about what you want is it
what the woman wants that's the case
because I've been very selfless in
relationships I've got nothing back
right exactly yeah but so but if you
love yourself no no no but it's very
involved you kind of have to be selfish
I started to cut you off yeah that's all
right selfish like how though
when young kids involved well like your
kids are your priorities so it's like
regardless of what how anybody feels
like your child is your parity isn't
apparent to stay in that relationship
with two parents my priority is to take
care of my child yeah yeah that's but
that's that's being selfless like when
you have a kid it's not supposed to be
about you anymore it's about your kid
[ __ ] your happiness but that's exactly
unless you're in like extenuating
circumstances where you are getting
abused or yeah I'm with you I'm with you
if your child if your child's in danger
yeah I I agree but that's not that's not
the majority of cases if it's the
child's name danger you need to try work
out you know but that's exactly what
like for example my daughter doesn't
know we're separate my daughter hasn't
experienced anything different when she
sees us she sees us very amicable and
she she doesn't know anything different
so when I say something else no we don't
live in the same house okay but when I
say that when I say I'm putting my
daughter first that's the reason why I'm
not chasing another man or chasing
another relationship because the most
beneficial one is me and her father
right like see you keep kind of
contradicting yourself and you did it
again just here there because you said
your daughter you don't live in the same
house but your daughter doesn't know
anything's up she may not at five but
she will yeah and when and so and so she
might not understand it but you you
can't say that it's like she's not gonna
notice that her dad or her mom isn't in
the home no but I'm not saying there's
my my dad used to work here while my
family were back home my dad wasn't
present in their lives every single day
and I think that's another big
misconception that a parent or a dad has
to be at home every single day it's a
cultural thing is that did it affect you
and not having him there all the time no
no no
I love my dad like my dad was an amazing
man an amazing father figure amazing
that's why I can't trash men because I
have so much respect for mine I don't
think it would have been better if your
dad was there a bit often
my dad was gone a lot too and I'd say
like it did affect me like I yeah I mean
I would have been better if he was there
I still love him and I respect him more
than anything but like I I think it
would be dumb to say I didn't want my
dad around more
do you think he would have changed your
perspective on you because you said you
battle being traditional Western do you
think if your dad was there more that
you'd be a lot more traditional than
Western
um no I think the problem with me was
when I went to UNI and I came out of my
traditional or my culture bubble the
bubble so I think that bubble protected
me for so long and I wish I stayed in it
a bit longer because the trauma only
came when I thought oh let me experience
a bit now can I just say this do you
think your dad being present in your
life when you were growing up would help
you manage your situation right now with
your husband better because he would
have been able to advise you or even now
I don't know what your relationship is
at now but he would be able to guide you
or even have an impact on you in a way
that would allow you to manage the
situation better
I don't know I feel like I'm managing
the situation well compared to what
Society will tell me because there's a
lot of people that will tell me why are
you even investing any more time or why
even allowing this Dynamics because a
lot of people say OH Close book and rush
out yeah that's why girls give the worst
advice yeah
I say you're managing it well unless
you're still with him can I just no it's
like it's it's not you can't it's like
that's like that's not getting that's
like like failing a test and saying you
guys no when I say managing it well I'm
saying about I'm respecting his values
or views in where he is in life I'm
respecting that he's not ready to commit
to the marriage and children yet because
he feels like he can't be that
responsible
before that before
so right I'm so proud of you like we can
all see how much like you love your
daughter how much you're trying to make
this work like because life is hard you
know like no no no no no no she only got
here she only got here because she she
because before we said yeah that ah
women women said they lack the truth in
it your husband told you the truth
saying that I may potentially want to
step out on the year and that's what
started this whole debacle of problems
of relationship so him being honest is
kind of why you're here isn't it
initially it was the my ex cheating that
was the issue but you said you had help
for that trauma you said you had that
trauma no no that's something I've gone
in later like did you say within the
last year because it seems to me like
you and your husband split because of
something that he might do in the future
yeah and that was me looking back at
myself saying I was the fault of that
and so that was me taking a possibility
are you now saying that as a young woman
that traditional is the way to go 100
thank you a hundred percent I'm I will I
Believe In traditional roles I believe I
just believe that this Society doesn't
enable that and a lot of my anger as
well even in my relationship was the
fact that I had to work and I had to do
things that a woman shouldn't
necessarily do because Society now is
too expensive can I just say that
British Society though can I just say
that traditional women always work they
did yeah
no no no no no you asked your mama how
she worked she didn't leave the house
yeah exactly so we're doing the
housework and then more she's talking
about career I'm talking about Korea but
I'm saying that it all depends on how
you see it no 100 right and also if you
and your husband
wouldn't it be better if you both got a
flat with three bedrooms and worked it
out two separately that's the thing
money is the issue so if money wasn't an
issue of course we could have a mansion
and we could no I'm just saying is it is
it there is liver pot then to live
together
yeah uh yes
but
it's just easier for now because
obviously where we're not easier I'm
talking about cheaper is it cheaper to
live separately or is it would it be
cheaper to live together
it's just not a position we're at now
because we're only I've only just healed
could you just answer that yes or no is
it cheaper to live apart
it's cheaper to live together but
obviously if I'm not like I've only gone
through my counseling and are having to
learn about myself in the last year and
a half that time I was alone if that
makes sense if I'd never done that I
would never have gone through counseling
or learn about myself and what I and
I've learned and I think the thing is I
had an amazing father figure I had an
amazing childhood with my dad and my dad
not being there he was there you know
him not being there for parts isn't
impacted me at all my relationship was
amazing there was other things that
happened when I was a child that made it
more difficult
if that makes sense yeah in me in my
longer lifelong marriage and I think
once I then went counseling for that I
then realized actually there was a lot
of me that had to heal before I even
took that step can I just give you a bit
of advice traditional women
don't listen to the female friends
traditional women that listen to social
media and traditional women don't get
easily influenced by outside forces and
I think that's what you're struggling
with so you can't balance it too because
I know you're saying that you're modern
and that you want to be traditional but
you're saying that these are what your
friends are telling you to do and this
is what this person is sending you to do
and this is what the internet's telling
you to do and this is where your
struggle is against your traditional and
your modern but you said that
traditional is the way to go so so can
it be easier just to fade out all the
models
like okay listening to you
I think that is admirable that you've
been for what you've been through and
you've worked on yourself to know where
it is that you went wrong I feel like
the Social Media stuff the friend stuff
for me I'm hearing her tell me that that
is the past that's what she did that got
her in this position now and I'm in my
mind is that moving forward
you've you've learned a lot from how
what you did wrong that I reckon that
when even if it's this guy if it's
another guy you're going to be a better
partner than you are before because now
what you what you believed what you knew
of relationships before was from social
media was from friends or whatever but
now you've experienced something
different so now you're more realistic
about your expectations that is where
the whole traditional thing comes from
because when I hear tradition for me
because I'm Nigerian like I think
culture that's why I understand you
saying that you know your dad not being
in the house didn't really affect
because that is what this happens my
cousins are the same thing like it's
what if it's if it's what you're around
if it's if that's what you're
socializing if that's the norm yeah it's
nothing that's it's not on to you I mean
I'm just going to tell you how it sounds
it just sounds like a lot of excuses to
me
like it's just like this is right this
is why this is why this is why because
like like when you're saying oh it's
social media it's the culture it's this
it's that it's that it's like oh that's
that's why I did what I did it's like it
kind of takes away from accountability
when you're just blaming all these
things because
I know she's saying it's admirable that
you've got rid of it and that was in the
past and whatever I came late I
apologize for coming late what year did
you go Carnival
I moved on to Ladbroke Grove 2017. wait
let me just finish
I thought you talk a lot like this is
it's just like this is instead of just
saying instead of just saying being
accountable and you know what I wanted
to go it was fun like it's like oh I
lived on this road
okay so again I don't see where the
issue with Carnival is again maybe
because listen to what I'm saying when I
came here late I didn't know when you
went Carnival so all I'm heard from you
is that you've had the cats in a year
and a half so that's what I'm asking you
when did you go commandable because I
wasn't here so I didn't know right and
even when I went Carnival I'm a very
standoffish person no one will chat to
me because my demeanor is very like um
so even me going Carnival I dance if I
dance with my friends it's my
girlfriends I'm dancing with no one else
I'm going for a man I'll tell you that
right
can someone explain to why that would be
a bad thing exactly this is also I
understand you don't I don't know you
guys are Carnival for men but we're all
not the same people exactly
as a traditional
single parent with a child on the age of
five that's not looking no man that
wants to stay away from outside
influences that don't want to get
influenced by social media she shouldn't
be outside
no I'm just going by what she said that
she is no and by what she said I can
only go by what she said that's why
Pearl's talking about the contradiction
because as far as I'm concerned if I was
a single parent with a five-year-old
child the only time I'm going Carnival
is with my child on a Sunday and we're
going to be home by like six o'clock in
the evening I will not as a single
parent go Carnival without my job
Carnival's not the place to have a break
how someone what to do we're not telling
her what to do she's contradicting she
might not stop interrupting me it's like
she's contradicting herself the whole
show and so you say one thing and then
you say another thing I don't I really
wasn't even probing like honestly I'll
ask you wait let me I'll I'll ask you a
question you'll tell a really long story
and like it which is fine it's a podcast
that's fine but when you contradict
yourself like five times in the story
and people start asking questions like
then you get defensive and I wasn't
trying to know what to do I said as a
single parent I would have gone Carnival
I would have gone Carnival I would take
my child is what I've done that's why
that's what I see we're indifference and
I was a younger single parent than you
were yeah we're in different eras
obviously social media came when I was
about 16 even before this is an excuse
again
like like oh but it's the time like like
this is like your immediate response
with anything is like oh this is the
excuse it's like no I'm not making
excuses I'm saying I was battling what I
was battling then I'm still learning I'm
still like even now when I tell my
friends oh do you know what polygeny I
don't mind it a lot of my friends will
be like oh my God what are you talking
about some of them will be like actually
I get what you mean because a lot of
them have gone through the cheating back
and forth and all of that and they're
like you know what I I it's changed my
mindset so what I'm saying is where I am
now even now I'm still not who I want to
be fully because the more days pass the
more I do things even being a mother
even just working even everything else
the more I'm learning how much better is
being a traditional woman it's taken me
a lot longer only because I'm having to
learn that my mom's life was happier
than what I am how are you learning
just doing every single day the
difficulties of being a woman in the
21st century
um
how does that make you more traditional
living modern I'm not even more modern
I'm accepting that modern isn't the way
forward yeah but I want a man who is
going to be a traditional gender role
where he does the breadwinner yeah but I
mean we can want what we want but only
one in four men only one in four women
really get that traditional role like
most most women work so like the
majority women don't get that like let's
say like saying I want to be a
millionaire okay yeah like how does how
does that make you more traditional no
like what actionable it's more me
realizing how much the right wing
feminism shall I say or just that
movement itself has hindered women
because I feel like I want to now engage
in my feminine energy more and the more
I'm engaged in my feminine energy and
the more I'm realizing actually I don't
care if a man sleeps with tender girls I
don't want to sleep with 10 guys like
the more I'm realizing I'm not the the
same as a man in that sense the more
unhappy I'm getting my rebuttal when I
was younger was more because it was like
oh what if he could do it why can't I if
he does this why can't I now I'm
actually like no I'm being a feminine
woman have you practiced that in a
relationship like doing the polygeny
thing
uh not yet not yet yeah so so it's just
like that's not really that's saying
like I would accept it isn't really like
no it's because okay for example like my
husband now my ex or partner if he was
to approach me and say you know what I'm
ready to settle down but that is an
option I will 100 accept it if he was to
come to column yeah
I would but yeah I'm ready I got you a
side piece
the problem is is his issue isn't other
multiple women his issue is he's not
where he wants to be financially I think
again Society puts pressure on men to
have to be millionaires like there's
this idea that men have to be so what
would happen if you just said I don't
care about the money like I will I will
work with you like you can do your side
piece thing yeah I'm cool with that too
no I think but it's more him believing
in him accepting that it wasn't all I
want was it because in like the
relationship before was it like did you
is that something you got on him for no
never okay but it's he's con his concept
of women is women will stay with you if
you have money because a lot of men now
especially like the Andrew Tate lovers
believe that if you don't have enough
money a woman would leave you 100 yeah
so this is the problem is me I will
stick by his side with God can I just
interrupt you not to be rude but you're
his wife he chose you you chose him so
what everybody else outside of that is
doing is none of your concern and what
gets my brain is when you're in a
marriage everybody else that really
doesn't matter in the respect of like
you know your parents opinion they can
add whatever but it literally doesn't
matter so Andrews hate social media all
these factors they don't they actually
don't matter take them away and then
work on your your marriage or
relationship together
and this is the thing I can say it to
him all I want but again as a man he has
to believe in himself I can't believe
that a guy would leave leave a
full-blown marriage just because he
doesn't think he's financially safe
you're already married no it's not even
that it's not even that it's men also
overthink what we like the way we
overthink things have you ever have you
ever called him like God on your knees
begged and apologized got on your knees
and said I was wrong like you were right
yeah we've had conversations we've had
conversations for sure he's not yeah
generally I don't know must be another
reason why I've apologized and he's
apologized and we both agreed that when
he is it's more he needs to be he needs
to accept where he is in his life and I
can't impose for example I think a man
when he knows he's got a responsibility
especially a father a child and a woman
he wants to now make sure he's got
enough money to support and again his
dreams his dreams
no it's not it's not that he's left it's
more he doesn't want us to get toxic and
hate each other so it's more like if we
separate if he was to call you right now
and be like okay I'm ready to like can
we get back together yeah I'll say yes
so the reason that you're not together
is because of him then it's not me he's
not ready yet yeah I don't think that he
can just leave just because he's got no
money
back no no I think you guys are getting
again it's not that he doesn't have
money he's not he for him having 600k in
your bank isn't enough because he feels
like
again exactly I can't tell him enough
times I don't care if you're not making
millions no it's him to believe and
accept actually do you believe what do
you say it just it's just like okay like
it just sounds like there's something
missing from the story I I don't know I
don't know okay yeah this is where men
have to come in yeah I'm listening does
a man feel like women money is important
in a relationship 110 but okay go on if
you were now with a woman but you're not
financially happy where you are
would you break off the relationship no
no you're not a question okay if it's
stressing if it's stressing you out and
you're feeling like I can only focus on
money I can only feel stressed if you're
the reason I'm stressed okay because I
did if money is I agree with you in the
sense that men do have a lot of
pressures but I believe that's just the
way it is and and men have to deal with
that pressure becomes is part of being a
man okay but if I'm married to you and
this is why I think everybody's gonna
start thinking there's a piece missing
because even as a man and this is me
speaking as a man if I'm married to you
the only reason I'd feel the type of way
is if I'm made to feel that way so it's
either he feels that way because of
someone which has to be you or there's
something else missing from the story so
now let me ask you this in a
relationship you have to give time right
time and energy when you have children
you have to give time and energy right
if you felt like you giving time and
energy there was taken away from what
your dreams in money was would you then
why did you not think about that before
you're not married exactly what I'm
saying is when we were initially it was
different right that his goals might
have been different people change I'm
trying to convince him money's not an
issue yeah but Eddie if you were now
putting energy in like you want to put
energy in your business but you feel
like having a relationship is straining
your business would you keep the
relationship or would you uh focus on
business I'll do both because I'm
married to you okay now I'm saying this
if you felt like it was draining like
you felt like you couldn't give and when
I say draining it's not that I want
money I want your time right so as a in
my my relationship I want your time if
you felt like you couldn't give your
partner adequate time and you know
that's the only thing she wants from you
would you feel like you need to
terminate the relationship no because
I'm married with a child yeah but yeah
it's way higher than that so I think and
this is what we talk about and why I ask
a question about modern women and
selfishness I truly believe that when we
in the relationship it's not about me no
more so whatever it is that I need to
sacrifice to make sure this thing works
is what I have to sacrifice that's my
responsibility as a person who's brought
a child into this world
sorry when you talk about money
I've always earned more than my man and
I've never made them feel
any different list of a man they've
always paid you know they've always been
the man I've never it's never been a
problem and if I if you're married
you're in your relationship with someone
you manage the money you build each
other up you know if like you if you was
married now and you want I don't know
nine thousand a year
with you and your wife together working
at it they can build you're not going to
say well you know what let's separate
because we've got a kid I ain't got
enough money and we're gonna we're gonna
come back in another three years when
you've got money yeah you're not going
to say that I'm gonna work it together
I'm first generation here so my parents
migrate over here they came here with
nothing like to the point where when I
was growing up they had to switch
between he was looking after me day and
night because they couldn't afford a
nanny they work through these things to
go so I'm thinking if if they can move
from a land where they know to a land
where they don't know and still manage
and maintain a relationship and still be
together to this day for me to come here
and tell the story
there's no reason why other people
shouldn't you know what happened you
know what it is
no can I just say this a million times
over is because this generation hasn't
faced raw adversity and all the
adversity they face is on social media
so for example like you said your
parents left their country and came here
and made it work your marriage you have
to make it work you have to put in the
effort
I think there's got to be something else
like missing from the story it's
literally okay I'm not denying yeah I'm
trying to make the marriage work right
it's I can't it takes two to tangle
right again he it might come to a point
in his life that he realizes actually
Surah is there regardless whether he's a
millionaire or zilch and then he might
be like actually I can see it yeah but
it's very hard especially the area he
was brought up in he was around a lot of
superficial people I grew up in Hackney
I came from like Eddie poverty whatever
like my family came here with nothing I
grew up with that that's my reality I'm
not I don't care about designer Goods I
don't care about materialistic things he
needs to accept that I don't care yeah
but the thing is you haven't faced
adversity together and that is the
problem you're not facing your adversity
together I'll say it one more time you
are not facing the adversities together
and that is the problem I I'm listening
to you and I respect that you're you've
been so open because it's allowing me to
understand your story and I can see your
making effort yeah but you are it's like
you're missing a part where you have to
work as a team and that teamwork means
you have to put eye to the side and make
it we are no no no no
I mean you can call him yeah listen I
wish he was here
yeah this is exactly the conversations
I've had with him yeah and I've told him
we're here we could do it this and that
again I can't change him if he feels
especially where he grew up in a very
individualistic mindset where it was all
about I need to do this I can't have
help I can't yeah but the thing is
because you've got married yeah and
you've had a child which is it should be
the other way around so he before he
married you he should have been working
on himself and came with the money blah
blah blah and said I'm ready you
accepted where he was and he accepted
where you was when you got married now
you can't go you can't put your child
you know back inside your womb and then
she regrows again but what I am saying
is where you are you have to work
through it together because because
you're working separately and as we do
have to bear in mind that this is
we got a 50 Super Chat and they want
Auntie to say tell us how to keep a man
auntie
she has some she has some some stuff we
could all learn from to say listen to
him
and make him the head
to keep it simple no no no what'd you
say last time
[Laughter]
all men will be happy
[Laughter]
no there is she got into more detail
last time
oh yeah no I just think
I don't know I just think that the
traditional women they always had sex
all the time
hence all the children and the happy men
you know they just just stay at home
they just worked really hard and
sometimes modern women just don't like
to give their husbands lots and lots and
lots and lots of most important like sex
how long have you really how long has
your relationship been 32 years and
we're still having sex regular oh yes
regularly I don't know old people sex
either right regular what are you what
do you say the girls that say they're
tired
it's time for what two times four I'm
never tired I'm never tired I drove 135
miles just to have sex with him that's
how good it is because he wanted to and
he said to me you're up for it and I
said yep I'm in the car and there I was
how many modern women to do that you
said when I'd finished you went to work
and then I went back home what do you
what do you say to women
um that say they can't do it every day
just don't put on your makeup and you'll
find time
because they always find time to put on
makeup but they ain't gonna five times
for like how long does it take to put on
makeup how long does it take to have sex
what five years what about when they're
crying what about when what about when
they're pregnant
that's the best sex that is the best sex
when you're pregnant I think it depends
on how your pregnancy is going yes if
you really I mean
obviously yeah obviously if you're sick
that's an exception I'm not going to say
that the man's gonna say hey you're sick
let's have sex and you're going to say
no it's gonna say because I'm talking
about every day in general what about
the jury what about a habit what about a
headache right
the biggest light gets a bit of a
headache it does no as in the biggest
lie that women say is oh they have a
headache I have a headache well then men
should know that sex gets rid of a
headache what's it what's your sex
really pain so you would upset that you
see there's a lady and she confirms it
honestly I have a question I'm not
saying it's me but how about for the
women that don't enjoy or like this but
then don't have a man
or allow your man to go and find a woman
if you want to be a housewife about sex
allow him to step out and have sex
because you can't just get you can't tie
down a man and then once you put the
ring on your finger then say sorry I
don't like it no more whenever you turn
around and says you're sorry I don't
like you no more that's a lot of rubbish
every woman having sex with you leave
her
uh wave six isn't like the main thing in
a relationship what what kind of
relationship is that it's not the main
thing but it's extremely important you
need to be connected on it listen right
after your children it's sex with your
man okay yeah you need sex to be healthy
what if the guy doesn't want to have sex
with the girl oh my god well then he's
getting he's dead he can't be alive he's
gonna be dead he's got he's got to be
dead he can't be alive he's gonna be a
corpse I feel like women have a higher
sex drive anyway naturally so why they
keep on pretend like they don't and
don't free it up more often I don't know
that's not me though my issues I mean
because I'm an unsatisfying the women
that's why they that's why they come up
oh please
how can you say that a man is not
satisfying you when people open their
legs and you won't say to the man it's
good many tips sometimes help them out
as I say helper yeah
if you're having bad sex it's the
woman's fault because she knows her body
the man knows it's just all hanging out
he can bang against somebody can get an
odd on you know what I mean but the
women know what they like so as far as
I'm not baggy but you know what I mean
but the women they know what they want
is more internal you know I mean there's
more bits and pieces to fiddle around
if it's bad sex it's a woman's fault I
wouldn't be like guys don't like certain
things so as a guy you tell them it's
simple to make again that brother no
yeah obviously but I've got free fights
with the Twister the best thing is for
both
pelvic floors get the grip in there
explain the picture for what you like
and what makes you happy and then sex
will be great there's nothing stopping
it the only person stopping it is you
and by not saying anything that's right
the only person that can stop you from
having fun is you so Auntie is this your
is this your first relationship
[Music]
because it's the most sexiest
so what happened with your previous
relationship like why did they break up
or end she told them yeah she said the
bus driver but this one yeah but if they
cheat if they're abusive but this one's
a lifer so do you feel like women are to
blame for man cheats
no I don't think they'll be made to
blend of a mountain women have to blame
they keep on staying with the man and
then complaining that he cheats every
man cheats you don't like it get rid of
him if you stay with him he continues
cheating shop about it so if um would a
man cheat because you were offering him
good sex like yes a man would cheat if
he wants to cheat
one that doesn't they're the Rarity but
they're out there
so if you were like just say the
traditional good woman why did the man
cheat or what happened that's a
traditional room is going I've got
nothing to do with his dick he does what
he likes with it
as a traditional woman how can I tell
how can I say
the men will tell you it doesn't matter
it's not I did take it personal it's not
about oh they're in love with this woman
that's what it's just like as the I
heard a young man say they've got a nut
to bust and they did that's it but why
would he not bust it with you like maybe
you went there at the time you could
have been at work and she was hot and
cold she was hot and available
like Eddie was saying earlier sex is
different for guys than it is for girls
we not all girls some girls can just
have sex but some most girls have an
emotional level to it whereas guys can
just bust a nut to anybody
it doesn't matter
because [ __ ] happens like if he's gonna
cheat he's going to cheat there's
nothing you can do to stop and often the
guy's an achieve a gun don't even look
as good as his main girls are so that's
how you know that's how you know a
brother is a dog when these girls look
he's like cool if the girl's nicer then
you can kind of validate that cool it
makes sense but more time is just she
was there rat plays right time right
circumstances and [ __ ] went live I'm not
advocating for it I'm not advocating
like I said I say modern day men need
discipline do boys ever look back and
think oh you know what my girl's
actually really pretty why did I cheat
with this of course as soon as they must
have not they think that straight away
it doesn't get hard over that girl and
then take you on holiday that's how you
know it's on my team you stop buying you
bear [ __ ]
that's how much he loves you that's how
much he loves you because as soon as he
bust that night he's like you know what
I miss my babes
it's the worst day when you realize you
have to worry about ugly girls too
you're like yeah
I said
um women don't like eight percent of men
men don't have that standard they just
they like they're like 50 they swear on
50 of the time yeah they would probably
just
if they're in front of if the woman's in
front of them that goes up to 80 90.
what did you say earlier you said if the
if the guy turns the girl down for sex
he should be dead is there he did she'll
kill him yeah no I mean I wouldn't
they've got to be so wrong with the girl
because I can't see no man turning to
anyone that's why I said he must be like
a corpse
nah I don't disagree with that It's
gotta be something that's
maybe it's a fishy smell I don't know
maybe already
no no no no no no no this is what I have
to come in because at cool I believe
fundamentally that men need to learn
sexual discipline yeah to to not be a
dog in doggy situation so for me
personally I took a year out of six to
learn sexual discipline just so I could
have the power to say no when the time
was right so there was times when I'm
I've got a girl in bed and we she said
look I'm gonna come over we're going to
watch a movie
before I probably would have tried to
make a move now we're genuinely just
going to watch a movie because I've
learned sexual discipline I think that's
important but not every guy
I got invited
and they said you want to go and I said
I want to go to the movies and because I
don't like people in front of me so I
just chose their backs the background me
not thinking now we're older people back
row
I was like we're talking about what are
you doing because I'll buy for I said
listen right I won't come to watch the
movie
it's about the movie I said I've got a
house there if I want to go back to but
no all this Netflix and chill no no
that's what I'm saying it's a sexual
discipline for a man is important to
mitigate those situations for both for
both was that with your partner no
because it was a friend it was just a
date supposed to be a date okay on
fashion dates like back years ago
old-fashioned 32 years ago you're trying
to check me
don't [ __ ] up I'm 54 years old
my son's 36 what else do you want to
know no I'm saying was this date before
you met your this partner
yes okay so this was and what if I said
to you that it was a date when I had my
partner I'm just asking okay then no I'm
just asking does it make a difference no
no it should though shouldn't it think
about it you should it should no I'm
just asking no but you're asking for a
stupid reason because it should no I'm
asking because
you said um old people because obviously
because you said something about old
people that sounds 36 so I've got to say
that in it no no but I just thought that
you went like obviously if you went in
your even early 20s you're not old you
get what I mean it's only because you
said oh as old people you know you
didn't know what the back was so I
thought 20 is not old do you get what I
mean that's what I was asking you yeah
like would it make a difference she's
still not getting what I'm saying
because it should make a difference it
should make a difference yeah why are
you asking the question basically the
answer for you shouldn't be yeah
like as old people something you know
what I'm saying is that you're missing
the point
because if I'm saying to you that I'm in
a relationship and I've been on a date
you're not interested in that no because
you're saying you're a traditional woman
so I know that's not the fact I'm gonna
be a traditional woman I'm not married
I'm having sex regular I'm not
traditional I thought you were
traditional sorry I can't be no no no no
no no no no sorry okay I'll come for
your traditional at all I would not say
I would say that I'm old
er
no I'm not traditional I'm not married
how can I be traditional I'm having sex
outside the marriage how can I be
traditional okay because when you were
because traditional way means that you
have sex in a marriage and that you're
married that's traditional so don't get
confused you can behave traditional I
might behave traditional okay but I'm
not traditional sorry and I'm not
apricot either no my apologies only
because obviously when you were saying
being a traditional woman is better
whatever I thought you were no no I was
asking you because of the when you said
about the modern and the traditional
okay because you stand a dance or being
traditional because you're married but
as far as I'm concerned when you're not
married when you get divorced and you
move on you're not traditional no more
that's the difference between you and me
you've got a chance to be traditional
because you've got a ring if you get
divorced now in my view you're not
traditional anymore because you're
divorced so between you and me I would
say Traditional Values doesn't make you
traditional
can you be traditional again even after
a divorce get married again will you
then no traditional is you're a virgin
and then you get married okay that's
that's traditional if you didn't do that
you're not traditional okay I'm not
traditional I have Traditional Values as
in I prefer like old school I don't like
all you know the dating apps and stuff
like that I personally don't do them but
I wouldn't be able to say I am
traditional because I've had sex out of
wedlock I've had kids out of wedlock you
know Dad I am I have a very modern life
but I just deep down it's when it comes
to love and stuff like that and values
it's you know what our parents grew up
with our grandpa Foundation yeah like
you know back in the 1900s whatever
so I I have um a question for the panel
uh for the ladies actually
if a guy had everything you wanted could
you look past him stepping out from time
to time
not not another wife not another like
Main Chick just like a hoes here and
there no
I don't know I don't know that should be
such an easy yes no it's not easy
to weigh up what what options you would
have because yeah he might be cheating
every now and then of course you don't
want that you want him to be with you
but you have everything you want but
also getting everything you want should
you then sacrifice happiness that is
cheating on you you know wouldn't you
either be with someone that isn't
cheating on you and maybe gives you some
things you want and then you work the
for the other things you want yourself
see I would rather have my partner have
a full partner than have women he's just
said the question
yeah no I wouldn't you wouldn't do that
I wouldn't respect that no okay what
about you two
I think I did not like
seeing in this day and age yeah I feel
like that there really is no [ __ ]
thing is whether a man has money whether
he has a Porsche whether he has whatever
he's gonna cheat that's the like if I'd
be lying to myself if I said to this
question that I was gonna say you know
oh no I'd rather have a man that doesn't
cheat because if I go to the man that I
think doesn't cheat he's gonna cheat as
well so they all cheat that's the
realest like that oh this fairy tale
[ __ ] it's not real
it's very rare it's like 0.011
yeah but like is it it on his generation
she's she's that bit older where it
makes that difference you get it in our
generation I'm 23 I was born in 1999
yeah it's I it's very very very rare
that I'm gonna find a man that's not
gonna choose
it's not it's not rare one out of three
men are virgins are haven't had sex in
the past years
like what place is the story from as in
the one in three guys like is it just in
England or is it the whole I think the
BBC did that study you know I I don't
remember off the top
where's a very different place
it doesn't get better outside of London
I would I would argue that that in
London it's the same you're in a big
city hypergamy is the thing can I like I
think when people have more options like
women sleep with a smaller and smaller
percentage of guys when they have more
access yeah but like like in the
countryside the men are a lot more
traditional women are a lot more like
it's I've come from Lincolnshire and I
can promise you now is 10 times worse
it's not even City Center like we're out
by the seaside or you can be out in the
sticks like in the middle of nowhere it
is so bad over there yeah I don't I
don't necessarily like think all men she
like my dad's like top one percent
earner he never cheated on my mom it's
there but like I I just think it's it's
rare and so like you kind of have to be
realistic with what your like values are
and especially if you want a guy that's
like really good looking and gets girls
like can I just say this can I just say
this I just want to say this one thing
no one here other than Auntie maybe
Eddie just about myself just about has
the life experience to say that all men
cheat because you're 23 when you're 23
you've hardly lived an adult life I
think
but I'm saying for my generation yeah do
you get it yeah I do get it but you're
23 that's the thing so to say that all
men cheat at 23 it's like you're setting
yourself up
just not sending myself a dream and can
I just say that
when Paul asked that question
she said if a man had everything that
you want yeah straight away people think
about money yeah yeah yeah none of that
thought about you know I'm thinking can
you fix the sink you know what I mean
can you wear a plug can you please
that's what I was thinking about I could
do it at myself that's the reality
you know what I can do it
but there's plumbers no but the first
thing I actually thought was is that
everything I want you see the cheating
part is that something I want no way
the cheating part is that something I
want to answer is no okay what are the
things that I want in a man these
attributes that I like in a man
Direction the way of thinking the way of
leading these things are rare in men
anyway so I know in myself if I find a
man like that and he cheats I'm not
gonna be feeling it but who knows I
might just yeah you know I'm like this
terrible I just because but
I will say this wouldn't like what
Auntie said when Paul asked that
question a lot of people think of
materialistic things and that's the
point isn't it what can you buy me is he
giving me a nice house is he giving me
um the ability to spend my money is he
giving me Financial Freedom without me
working for it is he fulfilling my
entitlement I understand that's not
obviously it's come across I've said
Porsche this stuff no not you no just in
general like the generation in general
it is always straight away money but
like see see me as personally I make my
own money I've got my own car do you
have all these things that a man I'm
asking for I've got myself yeah it's not
like I'm I'm still at home and I'm
bummed me out and create claim Universal
Credit and I'm asking for a man with a
[ __ ] Ferrari yeah not at all I've got
all this [ __ ] myself so why is it that
you know I can't ask for a man with the
same level as me as well as I feel like
it goes without set like why do I have
to say I want love from a man in a
relationship I feel like actually go
without saying all these attributes
that's that's like loyalty that is a
relationship isn't it trust loyalty but
it's like the bare minimum yeah like why
should I have to ask for that because
the stat you don't the standard has been
the standard has been changed the
standard the standard has been changed
and outlined by younger generation of
women that the standard is you have to
have materialistic things and this is
what happens men adjust themselves to
accommodate the women in society because
their biological response is to breed
women get bbos and surgery for men to
look at them but they'll say it's for
them and the men no because you did it
because
you're playing into a man's biology but
then you're angry when a man talks to
you that you don't like right so if it
was Drake or whoever you would be happy
but if it's the average guy down the
road driving her I don't know what or
riding a bike it's not for you you know
what because of that yeah because of
that I truly believe now I've changed my
mind yeah yeah most women today want to
be cheated on I'm running with that no
I'm running with that I'm running with
that because because what literally
sitting here listening to what women say
now about
would you accept a guy that wouldn't
cheat on you but all think about
materialistic things Etc there is pure
men that would know that make money bury
them by these Tech nerds that these guys
caught money yeah but they might not
have the alpha and yeah stuff like that
but you really these guys don't even
register on your Richter school you
don't you can't even see them but then
you want to go for the guy who you know
is going to have bad girl on him who you
know is going to cheat on you but for
some reason you're the special one is
going to stay loyal to you that is just
pure delusion you want to be cheated
yeah
that's what I'm saying like like we
can't say we don't like it if we we pick
these guys because there's guys that
won't do it but we don't pick them and
and I say this because I've talked to
hunt probably what hundreds of women at
this point and the amount that of a
toxic X
it's like all of them everyone's got one
and it's like we have
yeah
that's what they say I think about it I
think the balance comes into play with
the tech and the nerds or whatever they
don't even have the confidence to talk
to women and they're not in the form is
that because we've made them feel like
that
I was just gonna say in this Society we
we reward bad behavior think about it
yeah look at look I'll give a prime
example example Jeremy Meeks criminal oh
his monk shot came out do you remember
this this guy's Market came up all of a
sudden all these girls like oh it's so
hot
this guy this guy came out of prison and
became a
models have 30 more children than
non-felons so when girls say they like
nice guys they don't
I think we've made nice guys to feel
like they they don't have the confidence
to come up and talk to us because we've
made them feel like that because we're
constantly choosing bad guys
I think they're nice guys don't even
want the modern women they just yeah
they just had enough of them men gone
their own way oh you're a big towel
that's it and they just go because
they've had enough I think some nice
guys know that some women can be
absolutely you said you said the onus
isn't on it's not I don't think the onus
of um guys who don't have confidence to
speak women's on women that is your
personality trait and that's got nothing
to do with me you know I think it can be
I think
this is that we tend to generalize a lot
yeah and I get it because I guess that's
what is in your in your view so it's
easy to generalize but I think there are
nice guys who because reading truly it's
not like this there's a lot of nice guys
that are single yeah they're getting
girls yeah and something like that
committed in relationships I think it's
just I think it's easy for us to
obviously say that you know we can talk
about certain type of girls and blah
blah because that's really what's in our
view but I don't believe if I meet a guy
who's shy and whatever I don't believe
that women have women I think he's he's
um personality anyway he's an introvert
or he's shy anyway and maybe that is
heightened when you meet other women and
he can't doesn't have the confidence but
I don't think that onus is on women
making him shy
it's not that illnesses on women it's
like we're responsible for the men that
we pick yeah yeah I agree with that part
but she was saying how um she thinks
that guys are like the shy guys they
don't have the common approach women
because
partially but is partially our fault
because feminism had this whole me too
move here yeah so and so like we're
complaining like they're shy because
they don't know if they're going to be
me too if they approach the wrong girl
no no seriously there's there's
a YouTuber that just came out where he
he approached a girl in public and she
literally called the the Park police on
him and this was in 2022. yeah but there
was guys that were shy before the
meeting was started
wait how old are you I'm 27. like so me
too was what five seven years ago yeah
how long were you really in the dating
game yeah that's the thing because I've
got another life experience okay
actually I'm gonna ask Auntie dude
Auntie do you feel like men approach
women more or less now when they
approach women less now because women
look more Fierce they were more war
paint
and because the men are scared
because nowadays it takes a couple of
rare things to happen for all men to be
labeled so now you don't even know
whether to approach a woman or not
because you don't know whether she's
going to say that you're harassing her
leave her alone and sometimes you might
eat this one a woman might just a man
might just want to say excuse me loved
you know that no
take your watch a girl drops something
and I've gone to give it back and she
gave me some dirty look I was like so I
took it I snapped it was Oyster card I
snapped and went and went my way yeah
okay and that's that's why a man just
don't approach women like your
personality trait you can be quite shy
and introvert me personally I'm very
very shy but when you are in a situation
where you feel comfortable you can come
out of your shell and with some guys you
know with some girls they can come out
their shell whereas other women have
made them feel no you stay shy because
women
I don't think that I think guys will
approach you if they feel good about
themselves so if they feel like they're
you know put pushing gym or whatever
that to build their own self-confidence
I I know guys that feel good about
themselves like they're like yeah I'm
good looking I go to the gym you know
I'm a nice person and he won't approach
a girl but he'll look at a girl and be
like no I won't approach her because we
we like or that girl looks so good and
no no no no no
this is the death of a feminine I think
a lot more women are masculine because
back in the day women would signal and
even when we had kit on the other day he
he educates women yeah he educates women
how to signal to allow a man to to go
comfortable enough to get um to approach
again
maybe the problem is men aren't actually
looking for women's signal before
they're approaching so when a girl is
now calling Paw Patrol is because she's
not signaled to you she's not showed you
she's any interest in you don't know
what her relationship status is and
maybe wait for the cues for a woman yeah
can I say this I think women embody
masculinity more now
no no but look at this check this go on
I don't know if anyone else uses tfl
regularly maybe I'm poor but you know go
on the tube you see the advert
um stare and harassment
it puts men on edge yeah
to like countries where there isn't that
a lot of men take advantage so it's not
these aren't put in there for women do
the majority of men are the majority of
men the men you're describing
sorry uh the majority of men Dominion
describing so the men you're saying that
take advantage of the country like where
this isn't the social norms where you
have to but is that the majority of men
sorry is that do you so the majority
yeah go on do you think the majority of
men are doing that in those countries in
those countries what going up to women
unsolicited yeah 100
and they're grabbing girls the majority
the majority of men in those countries
are grabbing girls 100 so the majority
of men in those countries are committing
assault yes that's your view on man no
no that's not my view on men that's
cultural differences in my country even
where women's rights are not like well
I'm not I'm not here saying women are
equal to Men I'm saying but if a woman
doesn't want to be touched don't touch
her that's even a religious side if you
don't touch it I'm with you yeah so in
them countries where work countries like
even parts of Asia Africa can you name
them
the countries that I've traveled to yeah
Morocco just say
um
I've had men approach me millions and
I've said no no no approaching
you said you said wait wait you said you
said grabbed they were they were okay
even in Dubai they grabbed one of my
friends I've been to Dubai I was fine I
had no issues yeah exactly what I'm
saying again and I went with my Twitter
and I went with my family family sorry
yeah
but also and again maybe this is where
the cultural differences are when it
comes to even like me traveling as an
Asian woman they don't see me as my
British passport they see me as an Asian
woman if I go to Dubai they see me as a
Bangladeshi woman and they will take
advantage of that thinking I'm a
Bangladeshi woman it's just interesting
um because I know a couple people from
those countries and they don't actually
have the same views as you
grew up in the like like um you said
well I think you said Morocco yeah
majority I'll say this
the context on which in which this
happened you were on holiday right and
you're saying that people grabbed you
what was the context of that group no
I'm not saying that they're constantly
grabbing this approach a constantly
trying to talk yeah but are you what can
I say as a Moroccan were you a tourist
were you in a tourist area were you in
the Medina were they approaching you to
sell you things what no I'll just walk
in the beach I was walking the beach
even if it's a touristic area what I'm
saying is some countries like even just
say when I go Bangladesh and I'm not a
tourist yeah and I'm in my own country
clothes everything guys will still feel
like they can they have a right to come
and speak to you okay okay
yeah yeah I'm not saying it's wrong I'm
saying again look at social cues if like
you said the guys teaching girls what
signaling is if she's not making eye
contact if she's not don't maybe don't
approach her especially and that's how
they make guys
but do you see how this is kind of like
the situation that I was describing
because you're kind of like like me
tooing these guys because they approach
okay can I just say as a victim who has
been sexually abused as a child it's
yeah it is deep it is deep and I don't
want if I don't want you accessing my
personal space don't do it
it's not just me talk to you no I talk
to everyone I'm a very social being
Eddie knows I'm very social you trying
to cross that line no like if I'm not
necessarily the guy's fault because if
he I personally myself I've been through
the same thing but I would never be able
to look at a guy and say you know it's
your fault if I'm getting mad that
you're coming up and talk to me I'm not
saying I get mad he doesn't he doesn't
know what's happened to you so he
shouldn't be able to feel like too shy
to still come true I will never call a
man or call police on a man trying to
say hello to me at the park I will smile
and I'll go on my way if he is now
following me and trying to take
advantage of that situation yes I will
panic and that's again my traumas I'll
Panic if he understands oh she doesn't
want to say hello and he might his
business there's no problem that's what
it is but you said the majority of men
are grabbing girls
and that's and that's where like I have
an issue with that because I don't think
you're correct I know people from those
countries and they would not say the
same thing so it's interesting to me
that's your view because to me that's
like that's like your view on men
I'm not saying that it doesn't happen
I'm not saying it doesn't happen we're
saying it's not the majority okay it
happens it happens
and it might be my figure it might be my
and that's why again I don't like to
when I go especially abroad I don't wear
clothes that will extenuate my figure as
much or my skin because I like to
protect myself yeah it might be that
they find me attractive and they want to
maybe every girl doesn't experience that
but every time I go out I do get
approached or I do get spoken to and I
have to now I smile it's not like I'm
calling police but I'll be like no sorry
I'm not interested or okay yeah no you
know I'm not single and I get I guess
every girl says that to guys I'm not
single then they'll be like oh what so
yeah you can't have a side boyfriend
yeah
I don't but I don't think like if a
guy's persistent like I'm not I don't
think that's that bad like no one's
saying it's bad it's like I don't think
he should grab you I think that's like
okay don't don't but like you're telling
me you you went to this country and
every single guy you saw or like let's
say so the majority so it's a six out of
ten guys you saw grabbed you no not grab
they will approach me okay but
approaching is an assault no it's not
that it's an assault but it could leave
hold up if I keep smiling and
entertaining it and not saying putting
my boundary on he might think oh she's
interested and it's very hard for when
times I feel like we say yes just
because it's easier like I take guy's
number just because that's not their
fault like to me like if a guy
approaches me again again like it's
annoying but who cares like I I've been
in like I've been I went to Martinique I
don't know if you've heard of it yeah
it's not it's nice and like guys they're
they're like at this beach would like
come up to me and I'm like who cares I'd
be like go away okay but maybe um sorry
babes I think it can be intimidating I
think the way a person can approach you
like I think some people I think it
depends on each Essence like how you are
I guess but I think sometimes the way
even the way a guy will approach you can
make you uncomfortable I'm a confident
person
and I've had guys approach me that's
made me feel intimidated I've given guys
my number just so that this interaction
can end I've had some I went to a party
one time and the guy was like I think it
was a security at the venue and I left
and I didn't realize he was following me
and I'm walking down a dark Road I get
in my car thankfully as soon as I get in
the car I lock the doors I lock the door
he's like he's like oh without trying to
get my attention I was like oh I'm not
interested because this is I feel unsafe
in this situation he stood there he
stood there getting his phone now like
he's talking to me I'm looking at him
like bro and I was annoying because I
was in the tight space I couldn't just
kind of just drive off so I think some
guys it can be like it's just the way
they approach they don't approach you in
a way that makes you feel comfortable
I'm with you right I'm saying a majority
that's my that's my problem is when you
guys are saying that's the majority of
men so that means six out of ten guys
are approaching you in that way we're
not saying it doesn't have countries
we're just saying it's not the majority
maybe like I'm using the words
I'm using the words that you said okay
majority of men will physically grab me
but they will try to come in my personal
space and they might try to put their
hand around me they might try to I just
think what what world are you in that's
six out of ten men are approaching well
amazing again maybe it's a young lady
the young lady at the end they don't
know her name the young lady at the end
I've had lots of friends go to Morocco
and depending on where they go it
depends on how they get treated and the
tourist areas people approach people and
when you travel so it might be the
majority in that particular area
no but you're saying the majority of men
in Morocco
in this country we have these
Protections in other countries we don't
yeah and when I've traveled to other
countries it's obviously going to be
touristy areas men have been quite in my
space and then I asked you is it the
majority majority of men in that time
have been in my face I said in those
countries and you said yes well I
promise to God we will clip this
so can I say that I do think that as
much that she can go to Morocco I can go
to Morocco we go to the exact same place
different experiences so I think each
person's experience that whatever they
say whatever conversation they have is
going to be based off their experiences
it could be a thing where when she does
go out maybe she goes out seven days a
week maybe four hours seven days a week
she feels harassed by men and that's
that's her and we can travel in the same
place
this is dangerous
but that that that that is dangerous so
you feel harassed were you harassed yes
feeling harassed is not harassing I
don't know if I feel harassed because
I've been harassed yeah what what is her
what is harassment
being arrested what is feeling harassed
feeling walking down the road and the
man could be walking behind you and you
turn right he turns right he turned left
he turns left you might feel her ass
he's actually going the same direction
you are okay and then you can be you the
man could follow you talking to you
excuse me can I have your number can I
have your number touch you can have your
number following you that is be in him
okay that's what happens the being
harassed happens
so him following me every step I'm
taking and trying to get my number is
what happened so we're not saying that
it doesn't happen we're just saying it's
not the majority of men and like I said
maybe again my figure my figure might
attract a lot more men than someone or
someone else might be size 6 and not
attracted right men might not be
attracted to that my figure might be
what attracts them and when I go on the
streets of Marrakech they might feel
like oh this is a nice one I don't know
I can't say my experience with someone
else is going to be exactly the same but
what I have experienced when I have gone
to certain countries I have been
physically touched and again maybe it's
because I'm too smiley sometimes when
I'm too smiley guys think they can
physically just come and get a bit more
comfortable so I had to be a bit more
standoffish okay I'm gonna Read Super
Chat um guys make sure you like the
video that is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these live
streams so if you think this is
entertaining you like the topics that we
cover and you think it's important that
people watch make sure you like the
video
um we are using all super chats to get
blessing an 8K camera we're going to be
filming some reaction videos and we I
want you guys to see the freckles on my
face that is what I want I want to be so
clear you can literally see the freckles
on my face
so make sure you send donations to help
us raise that we're about I don't know 2
000 short from that so make sure you
send donations for that so zero Fallout
one the men that approached her were
from from Greenpeace making sure she
wasn't
accidentally harpooned 90 free Tope
women act like celebrities they treat
men like Paparazzi the men in your life
are sad you view men as bad we love you
Auntie Christopher cerdak approach her
for her figure only to offer some celery
in a diet book
um zero Fallout she's a Madison
tracks advances from attractive guys are
accepted differently from less desirable
guys doing the same approach it's
Russian Roulette for a guy to approach
women they don't know whether or she'll
accept you Bill Bill Chris why are we
complaining Western men Western men with
men from third world countries and
acting like they're the same public
sculpture sadly the truth is that it's
more beneficial to be a toxic man than a
nice guy because women will choose the
toxic guy over the nice guy I'm
Christopher surdak pillow girl just
accept that you're a misandrous and call
it a day you will never be married 90
free to pay there's a study of men of a
man on dating sites telling women he's a
pedo but still got dates because he was
hot based on their messages to him Jesus
Christ
Peter Mitchell um for the girl in the
black I would treat you right and I have
my own goals like Auntie said the sex
though but I wouldn't cheat or do you
wrong dub Man Pearl explained to women
that we don't care about their money
because we're not going to we're not
going to be able to spend your money
Christopher surdack using words without
knowing what they actually mean or
making up definitions based on your
feelings this is the definition of
modern women men use words to describe
reality women use it to try to change it
came all you girls don't know how a hard
a hard on works we wake up it's there
it's we are thinking be or be thinking
it's there we go to bed it's there been
fact it doesn't show up when we worry
it's our Terry Crews 90 Frito pie pie
not pay please please the super chats a
little bit slower
um 90 Frito pie sex isn't the main thing
but I don't buy a house just for the
bathroom don't let me use it once a
month don't respect don't restrict me
cheating for man is providing and
resources for another woman not sex we
don't care about the nuts women thinking
cheating is sex but also say that sex is
just physical the UK Economist is it
true that women enjoy sleeping with a
non-committed man but not with a
provider husband 93 Tope who let garbage
batch doll speak passive aggressive girl
beside and he keep up the good work of
splitting up the family Almighty tion
Auntie is spitting now these
um
oh these modern women are lazy um Fox
that man doesn't want you he will either
seize you as just sex or he knows
something about your past that he
doesn't forgive you for but won't tell
you broke homes need to go to jail she's
got a big reason the money thing is
capped Tim nurath all excuses I'm
married we both work together and know
that we are both not perfect I
acknowledge I'm wrong she acknowledges
she's wrong but I can't I can see here
you haven't said anything about your
critiques always someone else's fault
steady daughter six years old
traumatized at Uni by a guy she keeps
bringing up could it be
daughter is six years old traumatized at
Uni by guy she keeps bringing up could
it be the kid is his and not her
husbands could explain the separation
Alice a call him Russell Warren love it
um Ruma God bless you Pearl you look as
tired you look as tired as most men feel
and we do this every day these young
women better believe the altruistic
ideals as much as they can and not see
the correct path isn't white or black
but gray
um Almighty tan she's capping she was
the problem LSA shorty with the tire pig
or tiger pillow is all caps Doom tracks
if he's not where he wants to be
if he's not where it wants to be
wouldn't it be a great idea to be that
woman who would help him get there
wouldn't that make your bond with him
stronger knowing you were with him at
the start
um boss Auntie told us how to keep a man
a few shows back a few shows back Full
Belly empty sack and peace zero Fallout
she is a former 304 disguised as a
tradcon traditional con artist no wonder
her husband doesn't want to get back
with her she's full of cap tracks um
she's a walking contradiction says one
thing um but does another tries to get
herself out of a contradiction Loop but
buries herself deeper and goes to add
gas to the fire when some of the girls
agree with her um how Cheryl Chad here
first time caller the separated wife is
genuine she's looking to figure out the
female proverb of Jane Austen in this in
the streets and 50 Shades in the sheets
ask cool Auntie how to regain proper
femininity she brings to the bedroom
spice the couples are looking for um
Russell Warren interesting um Doug MPA
the girl on the couch is a typical
Western woman encouraging bro broken
homes and single Parenthood black
cultures lost what a shame Goku with
Hellcat wow that woman is dishonest as
hell Russell Warren lead by example
don't worry about teaching lessons it
usually comes off sideways Paula what
she is saying is if a better option
if a better option than my husband will
appear I'm gone life is not a fairy pale
fairy tale go back to your husband and
work out with your family Karen Hunter
ma'am in the back it doesn't matter
they're already together so they should
get it together they the the through the
obstacle the strength is gained Tim
Jennings hot take both parties are
responsible for sex men have a duty to
protect women's Purity and women have a
duty to Value their only Purity dubman
Pearl asked the panel if a guy told you
I want to be with you and still have
other women would you say sounds great
thanks for being honest Alistar Horton
Psy more evidence of motion is a
weakness it's consistent and endless um
Ona hi I live in Nigeria we don't like
baby mamas oh that's from the last show
oh shoot
damn all right
um oh wait no no I lied that was from
the show okay sorry they keep going
um Omi Roma a man will not cheat if his
woman drains him every day he will not
have the energy to do so um rashu
bezos's ex-wife is already getting a
divorce um Tim Jennings after watching
the past eight episodes it seems like
abstinence is the way to go solves all
the problems no comparisons no messy
relationships making dating choices
based on all the other stuff besides sex
Grindr women will mess up your car if
you tell them the truth okay I actually
it's funny they brought up Jeff oh does
anyone have anything to say to the super
chats I'm sorry I didn't say them they
did
that one that was super fast yeah
um there's always a lot um okay so today
we're going to talk about
Jeff bezos's ex-wife
so do everyone know who Jeff Bezos is
Auntie you don't
Amazon guy Amazon I don't know if Amazon
it's like one of the so he's one of the
richest
he's one of the richest men on the
planet
um and so about a couple years ago it
came out that he was cheating on his
wife at the time and his wife was there
from the beginning so she was like
they've been together I don't know like
20 years something like that and she
divorced him took half the money and got
remarried and at the time everyone was
saying I was so sweet she married a
teacher
and it all seemed like you know she got
the fairy tale ending however
she is now divorcing her second husband
so knowing that women typically don't do
well
um
when they date someone that's like less
than their their EX in their head should
she have stayed with Jeff
knowing that she can't do better
what
I think Bill Gates didn't he get
divorced yeah yeah yeah I guess you
wouldn't have known she can't do better
until she
we know people think you know the grass
is greener and if you're in that Circle
like you're I guess you're what you're
like the people you're you've got
accessible to you now are different
you're in a different war game like is
that you know when you feed a celebrity
I am now in this world I've got access
to of our bitterness I guess so she
wouldn't have known she couldn't do
better when she's already in that world
like what's it I mean what she knows
that now but she probably thoughts on
her so she probably thought it's better
for her to date why did they why did
they split up because he cheated it's
did they say that he was G10
he stepped out how do you know maybe she
weren't giving him no six
but she could have forgiven him talk
about it look how long they've been
together
but you were saying that if a woman
stays she's stupid then so if she stayed
with him after he cheated would she not
be stupid and look what she done and
look what she done made more of a fool
of herself she might as well stay down
Auntie didn't Auntie didn't say you're
stupid she says the girls are stupid
when they get back with the guy and then
complain about him cheating so like you
you make his life a living hell you
chose to get back with him and maybe
yeah maybe she could have given him yeah
yeah maybe she couldn't figure you
couldn't let go yeah so she has to leave
maybe she's just thinking about the
money she would get if she divorced him
that she could start again I think that
but she should have gonna find another
billionaire to match her money then I I
do think he was wrong though because I
do I do believe that if a woman was
there from the start then you owe her
that level of loyalty for helping you
get to the position you got to I only
believe that if he remarries or finds a
new woman then he just do the [ __ ] you
like because she's bite into a lifestyle
that she can never really I want to know
if she gets divorced or she got get the
teacher half oh no of course not she'll
be smart to do prenup just checking yeah
I hope she didn't bring up oh [ __ ] it's
not enough why do you hope she do the
prenup so it's nice for her to take that
but it's not nice to someone to do to
her yeah because he was there in the
beginning
did he exactly
she didn't get that money from the
beginning yeah she helped her husband
but that's why she got what she got but
she didn't like yeah yeah she didn't
make the money she took care of the
family she did her yeah but is that come
on half his fortune you're telling me if
it was her she could have built Amazon
by herself no he she didn't do that but
you know the thing is that was their
partnership right that was what they
work together it's like it's like men
when they used to pay off the mortgage
when women then divorced they were
entitled to laugh only because they
couldn't earn and they were exactly to
build that fortune you know the thing is
right it's entitled to his money like
that's so much like I'm just thinking
from the man's point of view like if I'm
building this business right and I and I
have a like I have a boyfriend or a
husband right why why would he leave and
get half if I built it so why do women
feel entitled because with them yet say
say they've got children he obviously
had to work like tirelessly to build
Amazon right she was probably I don't
know I don't know the situation I know
their story but let's just say she was
at home she held down the home for him
to be able to to build that I definitely
it's not it's not worth half of Amazon
you know billions of dollars you wanted
to raise two kids oh come on I know
something I grew up with nannies I grew
up with nannies that shit's like twelve
dollars an hour
I don't know if they had nannies or
whatever but knowing a woman staying at
home to take care of kids is hard work
no that's why you had nannies otherwise
billions of dollars you know the thing
is right is that she got half his money
But the teacher I would like to see what
he does with his half because Amazon's
still going to stay there I bet he still
makes more money than she does with hers
a bit sooner or later she's got no money
and he's still building on his she wants
to give her money away that'd be cool
then she shouldn't have taken it in the
first place
in the first place if you're not gonna
want it no that's different I can take
money from you and then give it to
whoever I want to give and spend however
I want to spend it but I'm not going to
decline the money because I'm going to
give it away I'd like to see it I don't
think she should have I'd like to see it
give it away can I say I think just Jeff
Bezos doesn't give a [ __ ] how about that
because simply because that's his
ex-wife and she got half the money but
he's got his money and you know this is
going to make more that's the right to
see he don't give a [ __ ] because it's
Jeff Bezos the average man has to give a
[ __ ] because that's his livelihood done
I get you but this is in context of the
situation I don't think Jeff Bezos
he doesn't care because at the end of
the day maybe all about this what about
this would you rather
you lose your money yeah but and you
don't have to deal with that woman
that's weighing you down for the rest of
your life and you can make some more
money and be happy and content I I agree
with you he's so rich he probably I
doubt he cares yeah he's so rich but but
the point is like why why do as women we
feel entitled to a man's money because
you helped raise the kid no but that's a
lot in the states right this doesn't
apply like in most other okay but we're
not we're in the UK even in the UK women
don't naturally that's not good
that's not true um even I don't
necessarily know what it is for divorce
but from I've heard a lot of like I get
DMS from people constantly and I've
gotten horror stories from Men in the UK
and I I do Street interviews horror
stories of Child Support so it's it's no
different and it's you're in the west
we're not talking about global if I have
to give up my career for you to build
something and then you cheat on me and
we have to get divorced big man give me
my money
because you feel like a ways but that's
how the courts see it the courts see it
as it's fair for a woman to get this
like we're saying about the West the
reason that this is a law is because the
courts have decided not women that it's
fair for women especially where they
couldn't maybe have an income
no but the context is the court is
money men pay
and then women claim legal aid which is
taxpayers money which meant other
taxpayers because they're working right
then what happens is is basically women
get half of the man's money because he's
working he has to pay the legal fees he
has to pay child support which also goes
to the woman and then there's a level of
entitlement that women think that
they're entitled to it why your children
his children are entitled to it because
they're the children but you as a woman
I'm not yeah and again coming back real
quick coming back to even the cultural
differences me myself in my faith when
you get married the woman has a diary
and that's the only thing she's entitled
to when she's married to the man he pays
for her upkeep and her life of what she
had so if she started off as a
Millionaire's daughter he needs to
provide that lifestyle if she started
off as on ten dollars a month that's the
minimum he has to offer when they get
divorced she's not entitled to any of
his money or assets while she's working
in the marriage she's her money is her
money his money is very money if that
makes sense when they now divorce she
doesn't take any of his manual assets
and if they have children he has to pay
responsibility for his children and his
assets get divided to his children
nothing to her so naturally I come from
a thing where we have like a prenup
let's say because a woman can't marry as
a gold digger this country this or these
Concepts have come from where courts
have decided it's fair for women to get
this much because when they're left
they're left with nothing yeah but it's
called business because men pay into
listen have you ever been to call have
you ever actually had to pay if you
realize the amount that people feel like
oh sorry the amount that people have to
pay for example with children there's a
lot of money that goes into the court
system isn't a recent this is a recent
law this wasn't around 200 years ago
what the men and women dividing their
assets when they divorce
there's also nothing stopping women from
working today so exactly so but but the
courts do take that into consideration
I'll put it like this when women say
they're a single mother yeah they're
they're not a single mother they're a
women they're a woman with children yeah
and then they become available if they
want to right if a man is if a man wants
to look after his kids and you are
separated you're not a single mother
she's a single woman yeah yeah she's a
single woman but in the court she'll say
I'm a single mother I need the money for
to look after the kids blah blah blah
all right
and she has control of how the money is
spent so she can spend it and she's
actually she won't and she's
incentivized to not let the man see the
kids like she's literally paid to
because she gets more child support if
if the father doesn't see the kids yeah
and I think that's toxic women who put
themselves before their children
yeah but again A woman has to look at
herself and say what if like you said
it's about her children from then if she
then thinks about herself that's her as
a woman okay but I can flip it back to
the earlier conversation when we were
saying about the whole dynamic that we
were talking about where it was
and that comes into play because the
woman is not thinking about the children
she's thinking about herself how she
feels at that given time
based no no rule but based on looking
through the phone getting angry all
these feelings what's happened the
projections that have happened that lack
of no emotional management and then when
you're in no no no when you're in the
courthouse remember you have to provide
evidence at in court for why you want to
see your children right if a woman says
this is I don't want my partner or ex to
see my kids because it's abusive he's
toxic he sent me these messages on
social media he did this this and this
and screenshots with were given to the
court she can put in an injunction
without that just that evidence alone
now that man has to pay to get the
injunctions removed prove his innocence
then pay to see his kids and pay pay for
his children even though he's not seeing
them okay so then he's financially
drained okay I feel like there's a lot
of responsibility taking off the man
cheating for example a man who's married
and has children he should understand if
I cheat I'm going to break my home they
should not it's a responsibility on
himself
we could say it's wrong but he shouldn't
lose how I'm not saying [ __ ] I'm not
saying that I'm saying if a woman now
goes on his phone and she's now looking
she shouldn't find anything right she
shouldn't because he should also adhere
to his own responsibility and not do
anything right no no but why was she
looking because she suspects this she
suspects because he might be doing
something yeah that's selfish man hold
up hold up when you say something you
already know the answer
cheating is selfish a man cheating but
also breaking up that home is selfish is
that but so he also needs to understand
his actions are going to break the home
what action is more heavy yeah your man
cheating or the fact that a woman
destroys her home for her children what
act is more heavy in a marriage respect
should still be there whether you like
your wife or not you should respect her
if you're going to step up now can you
answer his questions yeah what did you
answer his question what what has more
weight in it yeah a man stepping out
just busting a nut or you breaking up a
home where your kids will suffer the
results but you've just you've what is
more heavy what's more heavy you as a
man could have created what is more
heavy the man so the man cheating
okay okay this right there modern women
selfish I swear to God I swear to god
stop it stop it stop it stop it stop it
you're over talking me on my own show
that's rude uh like this is this is this
is the epitome modern women selfish
because you think because he did
something to you that that is more heavy
than you doing something to your
children no I'm not saying that I didn't
say that this is this is
okay okay you've talked a lot today okay
I've given you a lot of mic time and I'm
saying like that like I actually forgot
what I was going to say
I'm saying is the man especially when he
has children he needs to understand the
repercussions is the woman's going to be
hurt she might not get over it he's
breaking up his family home he's putting
his selfish needs ahead of his child no
no no he's not she's breaking up the
whole like this is like like women do
something and we still put the
accountability on men you broke up the
home
you chose to leave okay I think we're
not understanding a man stepping up with
transparency is very different to a man
going behind her back and causing her if
he said to her let me finish sorry if he
said to her do you know what babe I need
to sexually [ __ ] this woman because that
is that is something of me I love you I
want to be in a marriage with you but I
just need to step out you're probably
still gonna hold up hold up no wait let
me finish if she then decides to leave
that's on her if she decides to say you
know what he's told me and I can't
tolerate it I'm gonna break up my child
that's fine but if he's now gone behind
her back and she's found out and she's
reacting and said this disrespectful
this is very different this is a
nonsense this is just like a Fluff it's
like if you chose to leave then you're
responsible for leaving God just like
with these two people here as she was
there at the beginning and she worked
just as hard as him I can understand her
want in half but what I don't understand
is that if they've got children
and he cheated
and she's willing to split up the family
because he's cheated everybody's gonna
say oh no she's right she's entitled to
because he cheated she's a woman but
look what she's putting her child
through for getting married again
so what's worse putting your child for a
second bad relationship or sticking and
working out with the original father
sorry I I'm struggling yeah to
understand how we're missing the fact
that he put the family in this situation
I don't think no look I'm not saying
that what he did isn't wrong I'm not
saying what he did is it wrong I'm just
saying that two Realms don't make her
right 100 but him stepping out yeah and
button on us and we discussed how
meaningless sex can be to men we know
how meaningless it can be yeah so you're
gonna you're gonna break up a home over
something that was meaningless he's not
having it doesn't have another
relationship he's not providing
resources he doesn't love this woman
regardless of the situation as to why he
did it
the reasons for him stepping out do not
equate to the reasons you're breaking up
at home
and men and women cheating is different
like how many women get attention from
other men all the time all the time look
at how half the girls on the show like
they'll be in a relationship I'll look
at their Instagram ass pic ass pick ass
pick that's cheating too but the thing
is is that everybody's saying that oh
then cheating's bad you're not supposed
to cheat but what's worse
forgiving your husband for cheating or
divorcing when you've got children and
putting your child through a second
marriage that you've left up I was going
to be more traumatic for the child at
the end of the day we've all been saying
that when you get married it's about the
child I'm not going to say that what he
done was right but I'm saying that what
she done was worse hmm because she
didn't just leave and say I'm going to
raise my child we're going to work out
and co-parent or I'm gonna forgive you
she went and married somebody else and
now she's getting divorced with that
person and that's what she's putting out
traffic is funny that we're saying that
the woman isn't taking accountability
this times the problem starts with the
man
it does I just said that but you know
it's the way the way I think about
relationships and like marriage and
stuff yeah
I think it's it's a partnership
absolutely it is yeah I have to be right
to be able if I have children I have to
be right to be able to take care of my
children my partnership has to be strong
and solid for my children to be a good
result of this part this great
partnership right I understand that
that's cool I personally don't believe
in
staying in any situation because of my
children because I believe the way I'm
set up I might be more useful to my
children I might be a better mother to
my children if I'm not in a toxic
situation for a minute
please let me finish I don't believe in
saying in a situation if someone cheats
for me to me I class that as toxic as
toxic because I know how it would affect
me this is personal to me so I don't
believe in me staying in a situation
because I don't want to break the fact
let me finish in my opinion
in a marriage you know you should know
your partner so you know what it is that
I want what I will tolerate and what I
won't tolerate you know the boundaries
I've said you know the vowels that I
that I shared with you if you cheat on
me
there's you you should have been you're
aware that there's a risk that I might
walk away
so if the family breaks up you are the
starting point of that you started that
but you said they use it as a risk it's
not a definite there's a risk
it was a definite
who said that he must know there's a
risk okay
led us to a broken family you know what
I couldn't say I can say your fault for
not managing your emotions
managing my emotions does not mean me
tolerating [ __ ] does not mean
neglecting how I feel to be mature okay
okay okay okay as an adult it literally
does
literally it literally means managing
your emotions when things just don't go
your way
that you would do this and this and this
when you've got no children okay just
tell you what I would do but
I don't I don't know because I I think
they're the same women
when they're pregnant you're going to
get the hormones you're going to get
feelings your feelings changed then it
will change it but yeah stop
interrupting her I'm gonna feel the same
when I've had a child when you've had a
child talking to you come back and tell
me that when you've had a child because
as far as I'm concerned it's totally
different because you're quite happy to
say I've just turned around and said I'm
not excusing his cheating he's married
right to the woman she's decided that
she can't accept his cheating so she's
going to divorce him fair enough what is
worse exception is cheating or putting
the child through a second of marriage
because surely it's got to be better to
forgive him move on get counseling for
her trauma and then get on with the
relationship and raise her child then it
is to put her child through a second
toxic relationship I hear you what I'm
trying to say and if we're going to turn
around and say put your children first
all the women are going to say oh my
hormones I want to have my child I felt
like this that's what I'm trying to say
okay like a person that has no children
and I think are you so are you married
to your
part your partner that you've been with
why not I'm trying to see that I'm
thinking if my son is 36 years old
that's fair I was a single parent I met
him as a single parent and we've been
together 32 years because I refuse his
proposal that's it but I think the same
way you did on me I was still forgive
him because I think that him having a
bit of front with someone is not less
important than me and our relationship
and the foundation that we've built so
there's no way would I put even though
my child's old and I've got no reason to
stay because of a child I will stay
because
and we're better than the piece of
France
I have to respond I'm so sorry the same
way you think that I can't comment
because I don't have children I can't
accept what you're saying to me because
you're not in the marriage what is the
difference between being with someone
for 32 years and being married with a
ring for very different other than the
ring there's a difference what's the
difference tell me
and that's fine now I'm asking you I'm
asking you I don't know the difference
can you educate me and tell me what the
difference is in somebody 32 years right
no problems and being married for two
years there are people who are together
for 30 plus years and then they get
married and then they get divorced in
two years because of the difference
there's a difference
no no wait so so you said there's a
difference name it I think I think the
commitment is different I think the
level of commitment is absolutely
different to when you're just cohabiting
and you're living together on your okay
to go for however however
what is the difference
okay if you're from a religious Bank for
example but okay 32 years versus okay 32
years versus a five-year marriage which
one is more committed I'm I'm a
Christian I'm a religious person okay
for me I think that making that vow in
front of God in front of witnesses is a
whole different ball game to you being
in a relationship for 50 plus years
I'm not religious what's my religion
what what my beliefs don't believe that
I should go and sway before God or write
in a bit of paper if I think it's just a
contract yeah and that's fair I can I
can accept that but again this is what
makes a certain difference just if you
let me finish I accept that I understand
that but this is why I'm saying that in
my opinion there is a difference so
because of my backgrounds my experiences
in life and everything things I've seen
people have spoken to all that kind of
stuff it's just different it's just what
is the difference which is the
difference it's not religion it's just
it's no it's just making it available
I'm asking you what is the difference
other than that I've only heard religion
yeah I've talked to the different level
of commitment but religion is
it's like it's like this is kind of what
women do it's like we say nothing it's
like she said you don't hear me no I'm
literally listening to the words wait
I'm
the words you're saying and it's like we
say you say commitment okay what what is
the difference what is the commitment
okay marriage is something that you
shouldn't walk away because it's a
religious thing you do right the New
Concept of marriage that is done in this
day is very different to why people
married before and marriage is a
commitment you make in front of God to
stick by each other in a relationship
that you're cohabiting if you aren't
just say you might not be religious or
for whatever reason you can walk away
whereas in marriage religious terms you
vow to God that you're going to be with
them okay okay so so both of you both of
you you're saying it's different more
committed but you said you would leave
if your partner does something you don't
like like cheat
because you're and you're separated so
so these and this is and this is the
church
every every bought a house together
right and then we decide to separate
would the Lord see me any different for
being within 32 years or five years
married how will the Lord see me yes the
Lord won't see you as his partner they
won't see you as his legal partner when
you tick a box you won't say it actually
are cohabiting but again even then
you're commit when you're married the
law sets stronger standards on that
marriage and relationship and how things
are divided if there's an agreement
where you both own the house it doesn't
matter whether you're married or not
I'm not talking about when you both own
the house obviously it's going to
equally be divided that's what I'm
trying to say 32 years you're going to
have things jointly anyway Auntie coming
back to the comment you made so now I
want to flip it to just say a woman and
a man are married happily the woman
steps out for whatever reason she steps
out she comes and tells her man I've now
married he then walks away is he the one
that's now breaking the marriage I said
it's down to whoever wants to do to
forgive him okay so a mansion
they've got children that they should
both stay and work it out that's fine
I've said this before and people slayed
me through I I would stay you would stay
if my wife stepped up under under no
circumstances without the kids being
there would I stay but when the kids are
there I have to
can I just say this back to your point
about marriage and the kids not once has
one person said let the man have the
kids and you walk away that's what Islam
says Islam says not once has anybody
here said that because you're unhappy
I'm happy are you happy to let the man
have the kids and then you do the legal
part where you pay child support and you
you're not happy no you don't know you
don't know I'm happy with you you didn't
let me answer the question I would be
happy with that what listen for me I'm
doing whatever I think is best for my
children if I'm going to be in the
marriage and I'm going to be miserable
and I can't let go of this hurts yeah
that's not going to be good for my
children so if for me leaving this
marriage is actually will actually be
more beneficial to raise my children in
that with healthy parents I'm going to
that for me I'm assessing whatever is
best but I don't have the mindset where
I I don't believe every woman is is able
to let go of this like there's certain
things I might I may be able to tolerate
and but then cheating is where I draw
the line but there's something else that
you might be talking about I'm like oh
I'm fine
I just want to say that the women from
the 1950s would think we were so soft I
swear to God because they stayed when
their man had a whole family across town
and they weren't leaving they were not
wait let me just ask a quick question
yeah so do you see a man stepping out
and a woman stepping out the same let's
say we're married with kids is it
exactly the same I'm saying it's
irrelevant because
it is exactly the same no it's changed
no so so what a man cheating a woman
cheating means the same thing in a
relationship yeah because for me that um
the one the trust is broken I hear that
but I'm saying yes it's the same thing
to me yeah it's the same thing yeah
because okay that it's not the same
thing
sorry it's the same thing to me I
understand that yes I understand it's
not the same thing but it's not to me no
I hate in your opinion but generally
speaking is not the same thing because
I'm saying if I can accept for my kids
for the betterment of my children when
it means more for women to step on than
it means for a man to step out then I
don't see how you're saying that you
couldn't deal with the situation because
I'm thinking to myself I'm thinking to
myself if people if we all behave that
way then we wouldn't have a society
because if I want to act based on
emotion someone could slap me and I just
kill him yeah then let's all stop
cheating cheating this all stops if if
you did anyway yeah if you if you don't
cheat you don't put me in this position
to have to walk away so The Simple
Solution don't cheat and be honest if
you can do monogamy be honest about that
if you can't do monogamy be honest about
that and then that way I won't have to I
won't have to I won't have to make the
decision to step away I'd like to say
marry men who are less likely to cheat
but you don't want to do that either so
again but yeah
okay I'm saying generally I've seen
specifically right now I'm completely
generally speaking I could easily say to
women the way you can blase they say oh
just don't cheat that's the solution I
can say well the biggest solution to
development of society is by and large
is don't sleep with the same men who who
just fit one certain bracket but we
don't want to do that either but when I
speak about stuff yeah I'm speaking
knowing the kind of men like I would go
for I'm speaking knowing what commitment
means to me I'm speaking I mean this is
this is where I'm coming from so I don't
my social media does not dictate to me
what my relationship is going to be like
or my marriage is going to be like what
especially or anything that is not me
doesn't dictate to me what anything is
going to be like so when I'm saying that
if a man cheats on me it's something I'm
going to be able to deal with is because
I know how seriously I take commitment
so for me like breaking that is a
massive thing to me but don't you think
your kids future should be a massive
thing to you it will be when it comes to
like okay should I manage my emotions or
put my kid at every statistical
Advantage disadvantage that I possibly
could yeah maybe you should put them
first remember again I said I'm doing
the best thing that I think will work
even even as a Christian woman like they
tell you to forgive no but except it is
infidency infidelity and um obviously
abuse stuff is when you can actually
divorce and it's in the Bible yeah but
my thing is again I'm going on what I
don't know where I might be God my
husband does cheat on me I might be in a
place where I'm actually like you know
what I'm able to forgive this and move
on so but this all depends on what I'm
going to assess my situation and assess
what's best for my children if I'm going
to be there because I don't believe in
staying with a man who cheated on me I'm
bringing up every chance he gets I don't
believe I can I'm not going to stay with
you and then every day of my life you do
you make a slight mistake and I'm like
well last time you cheated oh he's like
I'm
I don't believe in that I don't believe
in Tormentor if I tell you I forgive you
about something I'm not bringing that up
to make your life miserable so if I
actually found myself in a place where I
cannot I can't I can't let this go
it's not he's not helpful to anything
you know what I would I would say though
that if a man steps out on you and you
have the conversation about potentially
taking them back you should only take
him back on the pretense that he makes a
sacrifice so like you so it's a
situation where if he let's say he got
two drunk and he was with the boys and
he slipped and fell in the night yeah
then he can no longer do that yeah you
know what I mean so like he should only
really get back with a guy unless he
shows how much he's willing to get back
with you and he makes a sacrifice to
have you build that trust back and this
is why I'm also the woman who doesn't
when something happens I don't react
because I like to have conversations I
like to I don't like I don't react to
stuff in the moment like that because I
don't want to do anything I want to
regret so that kind of conversation I'm
having a conversation what is it that
led you to cheat what happened what was
the circumstance is it the friends you
have yes you're right because if it's
different say for example you're married
man all your friends are single when you
go out you feel some kind of pressure
because obviously they're pulling girls
or whatever we need to talk about that
it's a change then I mean but again this
is again this is all part of my process
of assessing what is best so under those
circles classes could could you
potentially take a go back under those
circumstances I think yeah
yeah yes but if you cheat a second time
yeah
then I get that yeah but I'm also the
person who you I have more grace if I if
you come to me and tell me the truth
hopefully yeah let me find out yeah okay
okay
um so um it's getting late so I'm gonna
close out the show
um okay so
um I'm gonna take a second to read super
chats then we're gonna do final thoughts
so everyone give their final thoughts
please
couple sentences
please
something okay
um guys make sure you like the video
that is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these live
streams so if you like these lives um if
you want people to see the content
please like the video I like is free
also guys if you've watched two or more
of my lives and you don't subscribe we
have beef so make sure you subscribe too
okay Maurice the black girl in the back
needs therapy men take note please stay
away that's a sign of toxic Christian
um Christopher um
this panel is a bunch of four-year-old
girls um LP Berkshire she will not let
the kids stay with the father
um Mt Jeeves She's a Lady of God and
vows until her partner does something
she doesn't like then the vows go out
the window Mar asks Pearl should women
never break up marriages Christopher
surdack 80 of marriages have a dead
bedroom within the first five years but
it's the man's fault for stepping out
studies show that in the 2020s women
cheat more than men anyways
um Maurice Pearl with these type Pearl
will these women choose to break up
their homes to fix their man if they
know that they will not get half of his
money or leave them with the kids
selfish modern women
Dwayne Andy is a strong-willed
sweetheart I want to give her a big man
hug all of you younger women on the
panel better listen to your Elder she's
packed with years of window wisdom
Beyond her understanding mtgs when a man
cheats the the wide leaves and get the
wife leaves leaves and gets everything
when a woman cheats she leaves and gets
everything so I don't want to hear about
her I'm not concerned about the men you
choose Casey marvelously refreshing
female dominated panel Auntie is
heartwarming Pearl your format is great
but I see an opportunity to improve ish
could monitor super chats and Pitch them
to you live Maurice Pearl after
listening to these women on the panel
I'm convinced modern women are only for
recreational use I give up on Marriage
Peter message earlier was for the girl
on the couch in the middle I would say
being nice is wrong but being an [ __ ]
gets you the girl a lot of my high
school friends tell me that this is tell
me this when they tried to talk to me
only for financial help with I'm tired
of being nice sucks Christopher or give
the money away yeah that's what Amber
Heard said too lie after a while I keep
talking girls this is why you will all
die alone Auntie you can try and we
respect it we Auntie you can try and we
respect you for it but this generation
is a permanent write-off um z-o Jeff
bezos's ex got Alpha widowed red a cane
I can't wait till they get an older man
and no man gives them the time I can't
wait till they get older and no man
gives them the time of day this is why a
lot of men don't approach women because
everything is harassment tracks look at
the way these women are talking and
claiming that most men harass them no
wonder men don't want to approach women
listen how easily you demonize them why
would I risk my freedom Mar asks you can
find women videos of women sexually
harassed on YouTube Tim neuroth I feel
less intelligent listening to if I feel
situations also you're not a genuine
person Harvest 207 size 6 shoes probably
not a dress size zero Fallout the men
that approached her weren't from
Greenpeace make sure she wasn't
accidental over that one already okay
um so starting with you and then go
around final thoughts in the second row
so and then you can also plug any social
media podcasts anything you sell feel
free to do it now go ahead final
thoughts on like what exactly and
Michelle if you have anything like you
want to get off your chest
um cheating
I mean it's wrong to cheat but also
don't break up with family
um women are just as bad as men and you
know you should know the difference
between a girl and a woman with maturity
levels
yeah
um I feel like this show has been very
much centered around marriaging kids
which I don't really have much
experience on so it's been very
difficult to kind of form an opinion on
it um but yeah overall don't cheat and
have faith in more than women
not we're not all decades we're not yeah
like some of us actually just want this
fairy tale but please can you show it to
us fairytos please please oh they know
we want fairy tales
that's
it
um
that don't actually know what they want
and they're a bit confused so it's like
I mean some people accept it some people
don't like you know I don't personally
accept it that's not me
um
but yeah it was nice to be on the show
it was great um my Instagram is Nuvo MK
n-u-v-o-m-k let's connect
um I think relationships take a lot of
work and energy and if you're not ready
don't do it and if you are think about
the repercussions of your actions
equally men and women and respect each
other have conversations if you're a man
who wants to step out have conversations
if you don't believe in monogamy have
conversations set the standards straight
from the get-go
um but yeah my Instagram is Soraya dot
says underscore and yeah it was nice
being here
my last foods are just working
partnership with each other I'll
communicate make things work and to all
the feminists in the world the future is
not female it's family so we need to
work together
okay mine is um work on yourself men be
honest to women
um your children will be fine if you're
fine uh you can catch me every Monday on
no shade podcast and every single day on
the day after and my Instagram is my own
royalty
put the Children First
and
there's a YouTube channel out there now
yeah we made antia Channel she's um our
first talent of just curly things
um so you she's gonna be doing
um some live streams here so new content
to come the link to her YouTube channels
in the description so you guys should go
subscribe
as for me
um yeah I just need to I just think we
need to reach a place where we truly
understand each other and not try and
see things from a singular lens there's
always two lenses there's always two
hearts of the story
so she's trying to take that take those
into account when we're making decisions
um and then you know maybe we can
actually be happy
um social who's Eddie um officer the
domino effect podcast as well so you
want to watch more content there
um and if you want to come into the show
drop me a DM
okay guys um thank you a good panel
today thank you
[Applause]
guys for watching um there's one more
Super Chat to Pearl super awesome
meeting you in person at Victoria
Station today love I did I did meet I
did meet a fan today that was fun
um
guys don't forget to um like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel
follow our two clips channels um just
pearly clips and pearl daily thank you
for the super chats they're helping us
get new equipment in the studio um I
know we've had a lot of updates but
there's more to come
um also go follow my Instagram
just.pearlythings you have to type out
the whole thing because I'm Shadow ban
um on Tick Tock it's just pearlythings.4
and dot five they're actually going
crazy on my Tick Tock right now there's
a lot of people mad so you should go
check that out
um I think that's oh also four
membership tiers first tier gets you in
the chat second tier you get the Discord
and the Vlogs third tier you get to
connect with me on social media and
fourth tier you get a one-on-one call
with me once a month I I swear to God
this is the best bang for your buck I
know fourth tier is expensive but but I
kill YouTube so you should you should
sign up for that one if you want to
start a channel
um like the video on your way out don't
forget to subscribe and we will talk to
you next time